[Music]
and we're back i don't know welcome to
frenemies
what happened why did you switch it up
ah i thought we were coming back because
we have been talking for so long
oh you thought we were coming back from
a break welcome back to
we are back technically okay welcome
back to frenemies if you are a new
viewer here please subscribe hit that
bell notification turn on your settings
okay because that we have vlogs you
don't want to miss okay
i'm here i never had to slam that
subscribe button before on this channel
i think when people say it so we're
slamming are we also hitting the like
smash that like button oh yeah
and drop co oh drop a comment below tell
me what you think
tell me what color are you wearing today
on let's get that engagement up guys
what's your favorite food com do you
ever see that on instagram when like
okay so there is a campaign that i do
for a company that always wants to get
like the most comments so they say we
recommend asking a question
so like i'll post a thing that's like
love this great dress today question
what's your favorite color
it's like oh oh oh that's like it works
though
but like can you imagine oh oh hi trisha
my favorite color is purple
thanks for asking you know what people
do i think people like to be asked a
question
yeah but you don't read it i i read the
comments like nah i don't care
oh yeah it's so interesting oh uh oh uh
dragon slayer
big pimp come drizzler 69 says mike
my favorite color is yellow what is that
for a username i don't know
it's not like a twitch i'm gonna start
twitching i feel like i'm gonna start
i'm gonna start a twitch channel i think
people would watch that
but do i have to game or can i just talk
you can talk
yeah i'm gonna start that i'm gonna be a
gamer girl okay disclaimer also
yeah yeah yeah i i want to do the hot
tub
we could do a live hot tub for frenemies
little streams
that could be fun you started it you
gave me the idea i watch your other show
and then i get ideas i'm like i'm gonna
do that
uh real fast just a little schedule
update there will be
no mid-week episode of off the rails
and after dark will be on thursday
instead of friday this week because we
are moving offices finally we're gonna
be moving them offices this weekend so
that's exciting but just so you guys
know that little update
disclaimer i'm wearing a hat today
because my hairline is a little off
and my throat's a little raspy because i
was putting on a performance over the
weekend so
i was like screaming and yesterday i had
no voice so my voice is like slowly can
we see the hair
i just i know when you say the hair is
bad i always want to see what's up
here yeah it's just my hairline's a
little oh
so are you did the hair girl drop the
ball today well
it's a guy but no he didn't drop the
ball you know what it was i put the cap
on and i think it shifted
because we were doing a sponsored post
oh isn't he supposed to pin it like
hello
hair guy no but i think i was supposed
to take it off after we did the post i
was doing a
like a sponsored pose and then i was
gonna take the hat off and then it kind
of
shifted my anyways it was fine okay
you're okay we got the barbie hat
so okay yeah it's not a knockoff barbie
they got the licensing okay good thank
god
oh today's episode is sponsored by
credit karma
karma thank you so much i used to irma
my credit what happened i bought a house
they worked yeah it works honestly i
never bought a house before because my
credit was
so so so so bad like not even statement
loans would get me a house so
first of all i went to your okay we have
a lot to talk about first of all we went
to disney
we made a vlog if you haven't seen it we
made frenemies episode number one
vlog me and trisha at disney for her
birthday hey
i wanna make more can we put a
disclaimer on that sure
moses shot at wide angle
wide angle on the iphone so he could be
close to us but it looks but it looks
farther away
but a wide angle means the person on the
end looks the fattest and who's on the
end
freaking me no it was you and then hila
so you were always in the middle so you
had a nice skinny frame oh
my arm is like the size of the turkey
leg so most there's a moses conspiracy
to make you look fat
in the vlog but white is good we used to
wear disneyland we're trying to show
everything that's going on
there was praise for moses camerawork
i'll have you know
close to you oh it was only for the
sound i needed to be close to you i was
thinking with my phone
the guy come on the guy did based on he
was on an iphone at disney you got to
give it up to mo
oh my god i look so huge which is fine
i'm not trying to trigger anyone i don't
mind looking huge i'm just saying i'm
not that huge
uh i'm not high i'm not you look so
small and i look literally three times
your size which is not three times your
size let's pull up a screenshot do you
mind yeah let's do an examination here i
frenemy's vlog number one because i
didn't notice that and then we're just
like shoving our faces and my arm is
like the size of the freaking turkey
like we're eating
so hold on let me let's see if we can
get evidence
the thumbnail excuse me look at me
i look like you look normal you look so
normal i look like i'm a freaking elf
like
i look like i have no teeth like i'm
look like why don't you have teeth
exactly where are my teeth so here's the
vlog
first of all um i love this intro i just
want to play it for you guys yeah
that the inch has everything our boy cam
grants edited this for us
i was like oh baby i was like yeah jake
paul sue suing me disney schooling me my
life is over no jake paul dropped it
right oh we can talk about it okay let's
focus on this and then we'll talk about
myself this is what you want to focus on
first
okay so how are you feeling look how
skinny you are you're in the center and
i'm like so close to the camera
okay so you're saying closer to the
camera makes you fatter
look how big my shoulder is well you're
wearing this huge nose
i don't know i'm talking about the
length from like where my ear is to out
to my shoulder my shoulder doesn't go
out that far
it's extra wide okay let me find a
different shot i look like i have
so now i'm on this side and you're on
this side that's a better one because
we're more centered
okay i'll go to like go to
not this one no go to the first one we
did the dole whip the dole whip was the
whip okay now we're both centered in the
screen the one with like
there's a dual whip situation no go no
looks normal to me which one you want
you want a different one
i just ate the corn thank you very much
yeah trisha only oh
look that is the shot that i look like
foreign you look so
small and you look so tiny in the middle
it's something do you have any do i mean
i don't want to throw you in the fire
here
don't answer don't ask me okay you've
gotten a pass dan speak your truth
you've gotten a pass well uh and she's
right that a wide-angle lens does
distort
um the space on the edges of the frame
so i understand what she's saying uh
that said you guys are both about the
same distance from the center of the
frame no
what i mean no
put your mouse in the middle of the
screen like right in the middle
say what what put your mouse in the
middle of the screen
okay yeah so middle i'm guessing is like
right here yeah so i mean but you're far
back and i'm close to the camera so i'm
really close to the camera and he's a
little further back
sitting right next to that's true you're
you're okay you know what
you know what let's just listen dude
that i was thinking when i watched that
vlog it put on so much weight on you
yes that's my whole point that's my
disclaimer i was like that probably put
20
30 pounds out of please at least look at
us now like yes you have smaller
shoulders than me you know the first
thing my sister said to you and shy was
oh my god there's so much skinnier in
person that wasn't on camera by the way
that was in real life
that was in real life you do you are you
are very tiny like your only thing that
is like fat is your belly but it's not
really even
i've seen you without a shirt well
that's what i always say i'm i'm both
fat and skinny at the same time it's
it's
not good i can't say that about myself
i'm not fat i don't have skinny anywhere
well i'm working hard this was a brutal
week for me but i'm getting back on it
this week
yeah you always look like but you know
one thing that happened is like you ate
this corn dog
you just ate the fried corn and you gave
it a 10. i was like girl how are you
going to give
something a 10. you didn't even half of
but then i ate your dog
right and then eli didn't finish her dog
and then i ate half of her
i thought you edited that out or someone
edited it i didn't edit i wanted it in
but cam
grants he cut it out he's trying to save
you
hey he made the executive decision it's
amazing you can eat like that and stay
so skinny like that is i'm not that
scared you are you are skinny because
you are a lot taller than me
we probably weigh about the same i'm
about six inches shorter than you so
it's amazing i do need to lose weight i
know we're not talking about this on the
show but i am trying to like
talk about what we've got okay but you
are a princess on this day
look at this guy look at this look at
this skinny legend with their diet cup
i'm such a dainty princess oh my god you
want to see oh you know what else
i got really triggered after this so i
did an interview the next day and it was
for buzzfeed or whatever and the girl
was like
oh we just love how like confident
you've become with your body and how
you're not about diet culture and i was
like no i'm the fattest i've ever been i
hate myself i need to go on a diet today
because of disneyland
i'll tell you why do you want to see the
fattest picture ever taken yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you remember when we were
in front of the castle and they were
doing those professional photos i
hate professional photos of me because
oh i never saw those okay well i'm bad
at all of them so they're like okay
here's our professional photos
there is no lens distortion this is true
to
self okay yeah and so that you remember
they had me do individual ones and i was
all about it i was like yes i need an
individual i need a post on instagram
looking cute this is the fattest picture
i've ever seen in my life
and i actually have a weird album
okay i have an album called before
because like when i lose weight i'm like
these are all my really fat photos so i
put this in the fat photo
this is going in your before yeah this
is the fattest i ever looked i was so
triggered okay do you always send it in
the group chat
okay i've actually never hated myself
more
i cried like all night like i was cried
looking at this photo
and i was like i never want to eat again
i was i was
so sad wait but trisha i thought you
were you were a fat legend that didn't
care
until i saw this photo and i was like oh
you're like
what happened to the chubby girl who
doesn't want to lose weight she wants to
lose weight
girl is dead and desperately wants to
lose weight i i just gotta do it the
right way i don't want to like starve
myself but
okay here we go this is the photo that
made trisha cross oh my god look at my
arms
oh no those look like a ham chocolate i
mean listen i know whatever i say is not
gonna help right no no just help me out
because if i say i think you look fine
you'd be like oh i'm fat that's how you
think i look
fine look how little my head is
comparing my arms my arms are the size
of tree trunks like it's crazy
they don't look that big no it is so fat
look i have no elbow i have no elbow
it's so sad it's ready and my dress i'm
so
fat and i just was like i hated
everything i hated it
let me tell you something that makes you
feel better okay flashback to not that
long ago
when we were running with the parachutes
behind us yeah and then i took off my
parachute belt and gave it to you and
there was like
this much space between my waist and
yours yeah
yeah so that should make you feel skinny
yeah i did have a smaller waist than you
like by falling
look at okay let's do a forearm test put
your put your forearms in your mind
go like this how much bigger my forearms
are than yours
oh well i look like a turkey ah
triggered oh should i not touch you
you're so skinny mine is so
fat look push it right here put it right
here oh sorry
let's put a cup in comparison okay
forearm check
okay forearm check i mean
look my body my body stores its fat all
of my
ass ties and stomach look at your wrist
is so i have a petite body
you are so petite in the hand of wrist
mine is so fat i'm so triggered can i
touch
most part because yeah can you put your
whole put your
try and see like i can't put my my
things around like that try it
put your it doesn't close it says well
you have
okay well you're squeezing oh so why
don't you do yours
well i have oh you do yours because i
have small faces stop with this wrist
thing
what is it i don't know
okay but i look like a ham chunk that's
what it is a what a ham chunk
a ham chunk uh-huh i think this photo's
i think there's a cute photo
i wanted to die well let's just
photoshop it to make you look skinnier
can someone photoshop it for me
spread it memes whoever for sure we can
photoshop
this oh my god why did she have me pose
like that
oh well let's lose weight you're gonna
feel great i'm on it yeah yeah yeah
let's do it i'm i gotta try first you
gotta cut out the mocha
here let me see the coffee this is a tea
today it is a tea because there's like
gloomy and
is there sugar in it no there's no sugar
oh look at you stuff
and it says moises blazes
no i am for real because like i really
have been just feeling really down on
myself i just need to lose a little but
god bless you
all right let's let's remember it's fine
honestly like it's fine it's just for
myself i need to
you know i need to lose a little i feel
well i feel bad that this photo made you
feel
i got really really triggered i felt
really uh
i thought it was such a nice photo it
was another one oh my birthday i had a i
had a different dress and it made me
feel so fat i was just so
i was so scared oh the girl who made oh
i won't say it
so we went to disney you guys watched
the vlog it was fun if you guys like it
we'll do more i'm trying to think of
other ideas
to do and also obviously get more audi
better audio next time but it's not that
bad
um and then other than that we went so
trisha had her big birthday bash
birthday and i was like that birthday
was insane the party yeah you thought so
i thought yeah
first of all i got to say it was really
small i invited 12 people with their
plus ones it was only twenty five
dollars twelve yeah plus one
wow i think popper raging it wasn't at
all but thank you
it's like a kid's party my party's
always like i love karaoke i love
like you know benihana like i like a
kid's stuff so it was to me it's like a
kid's party
so she brought like the benny or how do
you call that the benihana
we had a whole hibachi show it felt like
it was your about mitzvah be honest
because everything was like decorated
the chairs were there there was balloons
everything was like cast pink yeah it
was a perfect night like
in looking over the hills while the sun
was setting yeah
it was uh it was and then there was uh
so okay it was all outdoors
everyone's vaccinated outdoors yeah i
saw some people be like
you complained about people shut up we
were outdoors and vaccinated that's
literally
what the cdc says to do no literally
everyone that was invited i work with on
a regular basis if it's music producer
in music videos and music videos and
stuff we always get like
tested but everyone's vaccinated now
yeah yeah totally fine okay just so
but i think it's good to put a
disclaimer because yeah i agree i agree
let's go
vaccination vaccination oh did you know
that vaccinated people are 100
hotter who said that that's a fact dr
fauci said that
oh okay that's like on the i don't know
who that is
you don't know who the fountain is okay
did you have fun yeah you you can so we
went there
you guys are so much fun we actually
spent like really days together that's
this week
i know oh my god it was fun so anyway we
went to the party
we got all dressed up in pink everyone
was dressed up in pink everyone was like
wow i love your outfit i got it on
amazon like three days before
it looked so good you guys looked so
cool i had like a pink cowboy hat i
tried to get a fedora but
they didn't was it a cowboy it wasn't a
cowboy hat was it well what was it i
don't know
it was some kind of pink hat and it was
like people kept coming up to be like i
love your hat where did you get that i
was like amazon
amazon prime one day delivery frogs the
pink rocks the pink crocs i was head to
toe
but um oh can i also just say i haven't
exercised in a month i i'm gonna and you
start exercising i think that'll help me
anyways
uh yeah i don't think it's just my
eating i think it's going to happen can
i tell you something
so i've been exercising and just to flex
on the haters a little bit here
i'm going in my instagram so i've been
exercising regularly
and feeling strong and now listen i've
not always been a powerful man
okay so this is our outfit by the way i
love this i was so excited to see you
guys ela of course had just
showed up like super posh i was like
let's have fun and just get a stupid
thing on amazon she's like um
say i'm gonna address this she's like
come on i'ma [ __ ] you know me dude i
gotta everyone loves her style
everyone's always like hilah has the
coolest style ever
yeah i mean like she's an icon yeah you
are too though look at those pink crocs
well it's funny i thought i was just
gonna look like a goofball but i ended
up actually looking like a real
character like
like i could see this dude on at a frat
party you know what i mean
i love it you also that's kind of front
of these crocs oh i have a present for
you but let me know when you want me to
give it to you oh you brought it
yeah because you got me all hyped up on
it last week were you hyped okay
yeah okay but so anyway reminded me of
it
so anyway i was talking about jack to
ethan from exercising so one
oh yeah okay no
jacked hair i'll click you know
no not that this and then boom
i'm not going to lie that wasn't always
easy for i don't think i could
necessarily do that
so you think you gotten stronger yeah
and i put her gently back down on her
feet and she was like hello
and she's like daddy she called me dad
oh okay
should we try to recreate that no i
don't think i could pull that off with
you a piece of love
i wanted i would i almost you know i'll
try it i think i might throw
i'll try it i remember i wanted to jump
on the disneyland
oh yeah talking like you're like i think
you could do it but i i just wouldn't be
scared i'm just no
you could do that because you were
saying you just wanted him to like
you wanted to do a dance move where you
hop and he lifts you you like lift from
the bottom i don't know maybe we'll have
to vlog it if you try to lift me because
we need to practice it but i'm so i'm
self-conscious about it
well when i used to dance dancers lift
me up all the time like i need to go on
tour i was always getting lifted but i
feel like now it's like i don't know
let's get that fupa loss people lost
actually
i can't today because well it's gonna be
a daylight by the time people see it but
today may 10th the day we're filming
this ihop has unlimited milkshakes on
our adam sandler and we're gonna go get
some unlimited milkshakes after this
office
how many milkshakes do you need what do
you mean unlimited unlimited as much as
one milkshake is enough milkshake all
you can drink in one sitting wait what
about adam
sandler start over start over yeah it's
on shoe boom today i thought it was on
chewboom so basically what what you
don't know this oh let me show you
how many milkshakes do you need it's so
rich one milkshake
offers all you can drink milkshakes in
order of adam sandler's visit on may 10
2021.
wait adam sandler went to ihop and then
left because it was too busy and they're
giving out milkshakes to commemorate
that
he didn't eat there his tweet was the
real reason he left was because all you
eat can eat did not apply to milkshake
so he was like i love
he was like i think he was kidding no
right but i have took that i was like
we're gonna market this and be like
here so we're gonna go do it so you're
gonna go to ihop and drink how many
milkshakes
i think at least three i like strawberry
chocolate and vanilla i like all three
flavors but it looks like an oreo cookie
one in there
looks like oreo so diet tomorrow
i'm i'm honest with you what this whole
this whole idea of a diet no
because every day with you is like oh
well that's free milkshake day tomorrow
right
oh but i've got a mukbang 20 [ __ ] uh
uh i just mukbang what i eat i don't do
20 meals at a time i just make me want
to eat
i'm just saying i got sick after
disneyland i threw up
you did yeah remember i stick on the bus
okay so and then i try to like hold it
together because like you
you were just talking to my mom and
sister i was like okay this is like my
party i should be like you know involved
was it because of my pizza that made you
sick
i don't know if that's why maybe just
all the stuff you know was it a curse
was it the domino's curse
i don't think so i think it was the
noodles we ate that we did not film we
did not film our
dinner and those noodles were like
sitting in my stomach in such a weird
way i think that's what it was
so um we did a food tour our vlog was
about a food tour
and we ate all this food and then at the
end of the day on the way back by the
way we had this big party bus for like
100 people and there was five of us
there
and a stripper pole no one used that uh
obviously and we were just getting so
sick because it was it was live
oh my we were sitting in the very back
and i remember i was talking to trisha
because she was in the very back and in
one moment she
literally does this like great hair i
felt skinny though i was like oh
i get so light because
the party bus guy was like was like
blowing out pretty good trish was just
like
yeah holy [ __ ] i got me out for disney
do you want your present
um yes i would love my present thank you
so much
all right let me make sure it's all
right and so we anyway we ate all this
food and then
on the party bus we got dominoes cause
we're like [ __ ] this that food sucked
yeah it was really bad the dinner i
think was not good right
which i'm sorry that was my fault it
wasn't your fault well because i was
like yo this restaurant's really good
but because of kovid they're like oh by
the way
you have to sit outside and our men we
only have like five items on you
on our menu and they're all the really
bad items yeah items it was like limited
money oh yeah i was like sad there was
like no
me by the way even your mom was like hey
can i get decaf coffee he's like ooh
i'm sorry you don't have a decaf yeah
it's like dude
they don't have like steak chicken they
had nothing like there was nothing on it
i got these weird noodles it was like
okay
all right all right present time all
right so what's the occasion
it was my birthday it was supposed to be
for my birthday i was gonna you're
buying me presents for your birthday
all right giving gifts okay so i got one
for myself too so we can like open at
the same time
should i close my eyes wait hold on my
fingers stuck is that because you're
is do you have a fat thumb i don't know
i'm just asking i don't know
do you store fat in your thumb i don't
know
okay ready okay wait yeah i'm seeing
them so i don't know either so this is
like it says
nike by you oh don't look don't oh it
says nike by trish
right here look it says you right here
no look at the side
nike by trish okay yeah okay don't look
okay pull it out this way
okay okay wait how do i open it
i just pull it out sew this up oh that
goes up yeah and then i pull it up yeah
yeah okay here we go three two
one okay now i gotta unbox it
whoa whoa
dude and we look at the back hold on you
gotta look at the back
yo these are hype is we're twins
[ __ ] bro and look at the no put them
together
okay you gotta put the the left and the
right together
oh [ __ ] friend friend me's
friends
these are super nice shoes so that's our
before when like our merch
comes out we could do like a cute little
like tick tock moment definitely gonna
do a photo shoot and
next time we shoot a vlog we should wear
our frenemy shoes okay
wow thank you so much you're welcome
that's some bestie [ __ ] right there
i love matching and since you love like
just see if it fits i hope it fits if
not i don't think anything did you ask
eila about the
yeah i was in the group chat i kept
asking over and over for your size
nobody really told me
you were in the chat let me check the
sets because my shoes really my f
my foot is they said ten oh these things
are gonna fit though they're like
you know what you do with a fat foot you
undo these all the way and make it
really loose
i don't know your foot's not fat bestie
status
i know it can be matchy thank you i
really want to shoot another vlog now
and wear these shoes
we should play like basketball with adam
sandler in malibu right he does that a
lot
oh for sure we just have to drive by
people say they drive by we know the
basketball court people say they drive
by and he's really nice one girl's like
oh yeah he came up to our car and said
hi cuz we're like adam we love you
and he's like tick-tock yeah so maybe we
should try
okay well let's just spend a day like we
should just go play basketball on bow
boot and maybe like get a little track
he'll see some camera i don't want to
play basketball but i'm down to just put
up some lawn chairs and wait
wait you're good at basketball remember
we played
our one-on-one yeah you're right yeah
wow thank you trisha here
that's really cool those look and i feel
like those they're custom they took so
long
so wait you can customize nike's through
nike or what how does this work yeah and
it's so hard too
like you have to like wait in line it'll
say sold out like they say sold out for
weeks and like i couldn't get them so i
think they only do a limited number of
them yeah i mean it's not official
friend of mine's merch but you know i
tried
it's better than official it's exclusive
black and pink is now frenemies um
so okay so we talked about disney thank
you for the shoe that's very exciting
now i want to talk about this insane
birthday party okay
so first of all i didn't drink because
um bro it's so hard for me to drink
these days but i didn't drink me neither
didn't drink
i know i drank and i regret it like all
day yesterday i was just like
even today i was just like okay i'm a
little out of it like i just took it out
were you super
i couldn't tell but i looked like you
were pretty tipped i was tips at the
beginning and then when we ate i got
really sick when we stayed on dinner i
was like okay i need a chill and then i
did a little bit more
and then i have been drinking in like
literally like two years like it's been
so long so i was like
knocked down that's what i thought i was
like i don't think i've ever seen trisha
drink
just like a special occasion i was just
like let me just have some shots and
yeah i thought one thing led to another
yeah i felt it like
all day yesterday i feel it a little
today too so i feel like a little like a
low energy i was like
but um yeah i don't get hungover i just
get really like
yeah you know what i mean i don't want
to love her i think you do get hungover
no i just wanted to eat up so much food
the next day i was like i need food so
there was like so much food so i was
super full but anyway
we were i mean we were there for like
four hours and then i go
okay trisha well we gotta go get our
dogs and we have a baby we gotta go
and you're like well it's funny because
ela's like we can't leave yet trish is
going to be angry
she knows me so well i was like i was
like what can we do we've been here for
four hours we're not there four hours
bro we got 36
and you left it like we left 8 39.
yeah we didn't get home until 12. that
is so not true
my party ended at 12. so that was way
after you guys left
we left at like nine i would say
no we left at like 10 30. definitely not
we could probably you know moses back me
up you got timestamps i have the time
stamp i have the proof i have the proof
okay so i videotaped you guys singing
your last song and you left right after
you did your life all right so let's go
time step that right now
i got it i got it okay so i filmed you
guys the very last song was
okay here's your last step right now at
1002 saturday eli goes to hug you after
you sing yourself
okay four hours i left at 10. okay thank
you
so that's four hours okay exactly i was
there for a longest time
yeah and so we go fast it didn't feel
like it no it did it was really fun
but the point is is that we were you're
like excuse me
the cup cake hasn't even come out yet
yeah well that was
it well i was like when's the cake
coming out i've been here four hours the
whole point of a party is so people say
happy birthday to you so you're not
alone and you guys are like
i can't wait all day for your [ __ ]
for like for your
servants to bring out the cake i paid
people i wasn't
so anyway the cake come out and then we
and then whatever we get the cake
and then you go oh and by the way
nobody's allowed to leave until you sing
karaoke
yeah yeah yeah that's true although
moses did not saying karaoke i was
little but you guys did it
yeah you guys were very much like oh i
don't want to sing karaoke and then you
went for like an encore
you were the only person to do like a
double you're like you know what i'm
going to stay up here actually and do
another song i was like okay
wow people loved it but anyway
i was really nervous because i was sober
if i was drunk i'd been like let's go
in the pool why were you nervous though
there was nobody there it was like 20
people
there was like that's enough and nobody
could see anything most people were
drunk so no one even knew what was going
on i know but it was nervous
you know when you get nervous and you
want to [ __ ] your pants like not literal
not
i mean like literally do you get that no
when you get really nervous it makes you
feel like you want a diarrhea
no did you no i didn't but i felt like i
wanted a diarrhea because i was so
nervous you know what i noticed is all
the couples at the party went to the
bathroom together like you and elo would
go and then ari and her
not in the same time we were just like
oh i got to pee and she'd be like i come
with you
but everybody was doing that i never do
that i've never done that with moses i'm
like you're hanging out
you say i have to pee and they're like
oh me too let's go to the bathroom
together
it's not like we were in the bathroom
together our bathroom is locked now we
don't know how it happened oh somebody
huh and someone might still be in there
somebody died in your bathroom we can't
get in our party planners like there's
coconuts in there might smell you might
want to go get them so we went to go get
them and it was locked and we're like
there's someone in there could you
imagine did you account for everybody
no because we we went to bed and there
was people still at the party we're like
okay we're gonna go to bed but you guys
can oh
that's happened before my house but it's
funny i don't necessarily love that but
i'm not i yeah i know
well it was outside so we like locked
the doors and went upstairs
no for real we did it was it was kind of
everything but um yeah you guys had you
but you killed you really if i was
drinking i would have that would have
been the funnest party ever because of
the bar
you had there and all the drinks yeah so
fun it was such a great party
but you did really good okay so let me
so let me
show some clips from the birthday party
because we have here
right uh unless you not unless you claim
my [ __ ]
why oh wait what is this
yeah yeah yeah i got that this some of
the karaoke got claimed but
so this this is yours this is your house
who's filming this
i don't know moses probably yeah yeah oh
this is what it looked like it was like
pimped out and then we had the habachi
tables here
branning i was like whoa bought mitzvah
yeah it was fun the papacy guys were
funny too you were vip sitting you said
i saw that i was like right next to
trish and moses well obviously
like you guys know moses like i was
trying to set people next to who they
know well i was surprised i wasn't like
under the table or like in the dog house
or somewhere
like yeah eat in the bathroom inside and
don't bother anyone
you could have gone in the house if you
wanted you would have gotten that vip
access
damn i'd be like can i eat in the
kitchen i can't do this
yeah you could have done that whatever
you wanted anyway it was really cool
and then that's nice
by the way oh i want to make a statement
that your mom and sister
are really nice and really funny and
cool thank you they love the show so i'm
glad you said yeah they were very
um because i spent the whole day with
them at disney yeah
and it was really fun it was i didn't
know how i don't like mixing
people in my life i like to hang out
with people like one-on-one you know
what i mean like
i only like to hang out with like one
group of friends at a time you know what
i mean so it was weird to mix
you know well they're great they're they
were really easy to get along with
they're really cool and funny and i
had to go to disney with a group because
it's like you're all walking separate
and it's hot i was so hot that day i was
so hot it was so sweaty
i it's just like kind of hard but it was
it was a good time i remember you guys
were all like super winded from going to
indiana i thought that was kind of funny
so annoying because like you walk
it's like a little incline it's like a
very slight incline then when we got
there everyone's like ah
i can't go on i was like oh i'm in
pretty good shape yeah you weren't you
guys you guys really kept up i was just
so
tired our tour guide kept running ahead
of us and i thought it was because like
like he was just trying to keep us going
but he actually said he's supposed to be
six feet apart from us
and the other tour guides were giving
him like dirty looks that that we
weren't
succeeded i'm not i can't lie the kova
disney kind of
kind of it's not as it kind of sucks it
didn't have the shows and it's more
expensive it's 160
a ticket now oh they raised the price
for me yeah so and but the [ __ ] that
really sucks is you can't eat food and
walk around yeah
and like so you get the souvenir cup
like for example the dole whip and
they're like here's your dough up you
have to dump it in the cup
it's like i'm sorry where's the magic
now [ __ ] that's like broadway two's
reopening in the fall to full capacity
but everyone has to wear masks the
entire show
was like that sounds awesome that makes
sense you're gonna sit there with them i
can't breathe with a mask i mean that's
the least you could do if you want to go
see a broadway show you know i really
want to see bro i don't think i can i
don't know well you don't have math
disney you have to like walk around we
walked around for like nine hours on a
hottest day
i know i know i was kind of miserable i
got sick i told you i threw up after i
think i really from the sun and the
eating i was like so sick all night
i couldn't that's yeah i yeah
yeah yeah but you know what the best
part about last week was like
i was so busy and not on my phone that i
felt so drama-free i didn't know what
was happening on the internet i was just
like living in the real world
that's kind of nice yeah you were a good
mood it was happening it was it was a
very fun good time
because i wasn't on like death noodles
you know then i go on deaf noodles and i
get
sad i'm like oh man drama you know what
i mean yeah you never want to see your
name on twitter
well it wasn't my name i was just seeing
like you know nicki minaj is not
following cardi b
that breaks your heart well it's like
drama and you're like oh my god i'm
stressed about it that stresses you
out yeah it did wow
you talked to your therapist about that
no i didn't see my therapist this week
maybe i sat here because i didn't want
therapy
i wasn't dredging up old so if
nicki minaj not following cardi b is
upsetting you then you're
then we got to work on that hey that's
good though i feel like that's winning
it's like that's the thing that's
upsetting me right now you know
yeah it's true yeah so here was my
favorite part of the night
is when um trisha's sister and mom
decided to do it i love you moses
pretty drunk at the time i think also i
could say that and not speak out
i think a little tipsy so then they get
up here and do it was like
i've never seen anything like it in my
whole life everybody
oh my god it was the everyone was just
like full attention
captive audience it is the best karaoke
performance i've ever seen live uh and
then trisha went in and joined them
am i up there at this point no this is
the whole performance i don't want to
miss a second
no i'm up there oh you are turn it up
[Applause]
dan
[Music]
the cords are so off
[Applause]
my sister started the hebrew yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a wrap that shows ready for tour
to take on the road
tear it down ladies maybe we'll perform
at the seniors
thank you
it was a weird version of it it was like
this weird karaoke that did not make
atmosphere no
it sounded right onto me and the words
where i love you jesus but my sister was
thinking i love you moses so it was just
all confusion
that sounded right on to me i don't know
what you're talking about give it up for
our atlanta california
the dj's behind me so everybody they're
like [ __ ] i was just like
oh oh my god it was so funny i love
karaoke at parties because it means you
don't have to talk to people you can
just watch what's happening on stage i
didn't talk to anyone the whole night i
was just watching the show oh god you
were having so much fun
i love watching people before she was
like [ __ ] like
typing everything i love it i love
watching well that's fun
that's fun and supportive because if you
go do karaoke and nobody's paying any
attention you're like oh
i'm the biggest loser ever oh really i
don't know for me i just really love
like
seeing people do that because it's like
people that are out of their comfort
zone like my director that doesn't love
music videos he's always so serious when
i see him but like
that night he did like 20 songs and it
made me so happy i was just like oh my
god just killing it
there was you missed a lot like the
performance got even better because
people got even drunker so people were
just like
going out but it was it was so fun to
have you there and yours was i think
yours was actually the best okay i'm
gonna play
mine and elas next after this after this
after this break so thank you guys
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
but now they want to help even more
with credit karma money spend account
you can be rewarded for good money
habits
yes and who doesn't want some instant
gratification
jenny and if you're looking for a
satisfaction there's no need to wait
with credit karma money you could win
cash reimbursements for debit purchases
i've never heard that a debit card that
gives you
like i agree it's usually credit cards
you get like
the points yeah but we're talking about
debit cards
giving you cash reimbursement boom here
just for using your debit card that's it
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account
where you can win cash reimbursements
for making purchases
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily
instant karma purchase reimbursements on
items up to five thousand dollars
and all you gotta do is pay with your
debit card and if you win you'll be
notified on the spot and you're in
the apartment cash will be added back to
your spend account
all you gotta do is spend it and then
they notify you i'm like hey it's back
in your account
it's kind of dope i wonder does the atm
machine or like
the credit card machine like shoot
confetti oh congratulations maybe
um we're giving away over three million
dollars
to over 50 000 credit karma members and
counting over three million dollars is
pretty that's pretty dope
open your fdic insured spend account for
free
there is no minimum balance required no
overdraft fees
no and
and free withdrawals from a network of
over 50 000 atms
credit karma money progress starts
here we still have to do this though
okay
you want to take it yeah right now visit
creditkarma.com
to open your free account and start
winning instant karma that's the karma i
like
go to creditkarma.com win money to sign
up for free and start winning instant
karma that's creditkarma.com
win money here you do this one as fast
as you can ready
fine print time instacart is sponsored
by credit card no purchase necessary
exclusions and items apply see rules
banking services provider mvp bank
remember fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
apply
okay we're back so first me and eli did
a duet
it says it's going to get copyrighted
but here let me just
so i can't actually play it which kind
of sucks i was i was actually so
i just love that healing up there too
you know what i mean because she's like
i feel like the two of you she's like
more quiet right but she even did the
rit
she did i'm getting ripped and it was so
it made me so happy because she's always
like so much more quiet and like
i was like yeah she's she's oh she's up
for things she's opened a lot
i tried to get her to go up on stage by
herself she was like no
but the fact that she went up there
moses didn't even get up there no shade
because most did so much for the party
but i'm saying like a gila would have
thread i was like wow that was
and she killed it are you just shy is
that what happened
you can admit that you're shy no but the
time we got to that that was too
buzzed you were just like oh you were
drunk
it's okay to admit you're shy mo this is
no shame enough i worked so hard for
this party by the time it started it was
just so done
okay okay you guys take the stage he
doesn't sing even for me like when we
why we're listening to obama i'm like
singing he like doesn't he doesn't sing
and he's good i've heard i think you're
shy
i think you're shocked but it's a bit
different you know like
you're impaired and some people don't
you're embarrassed ah
i mean and it's sweet we love that yeah
yeah oh yeah i would hate to have be
married to someone like you that like
you just everybody can have like a
spotlight and attention
oh yeah there's not there's the world's
not wide enough for both of us i set up
a stage for her or the camera
well that's what they say or the uh
we're literally so wide
we have a wide scope no but you know
what i mean like
i was with someone that like always was
vlogging when i was vlogging it's you
don't want to come back
for attention it's not even that i think
it's just like annoying if someone's
like obsessed with tick tock and i'm
assessing and there's like too much you
know what i mean like
it's a good balance i like that he
doesn't need the spotlight
i'm not like jealous of people who want
it but you know i just need all the
attention all the time oh i know
but i i like sharing like the attention
once in a while you know what i mean oh
thank you i got our wedding too
right at our wedding don't worry moses
just don't say too much
just keep it to a minimum i still
practice she'll share it for the frame
with you
the wedding's gonna be lit though i mean
after i told you oh my god based on what
your birth your bat mitzvah was like
your birthday's gonna be i have to have
a moment
before when i convert you get a bar
mitzvah during that can i ask you a
serious question
yeah how are you uh
you're gonna how are you not broke how
am i not broke
yeah what does that mean because you
spent so much money
i make a lot of money i know you do make
a lot of money but like holy [ __ ] bro
um like that party must have been pricey
yeah i think that party was pricey our
wedding is like the budget is like 350.
yeah actually probably actually with the
with the entertainment we want probably
500 i believe
i'm well that's a lot i believe that but
we're trying to get like a house another
house
it's a wedding and i'm i'm really happy
you guys have a house now at least so
then we're getting another one we're
getting a lake house
on the lake near where we live uh-huh
it's like a four million dollar house on
the lake it's white
near where you live yeah why do you want
two houses net neck in the closet
like a vacation house but
in the same neighborhood yeah we love
our neighborhood we love it yeah we like
went to brunch there the other day and
it was like so
nice and peaceful you guys really going
to try to buy another house in your
neighborhood
yeah all right but i think we should do
it after we're married so that way if we
ever get divorced one of us can have a
house like each of us can have a house
you guys are planning for the divorce
everyone gets a house we're not planning
but it makes it easier so like
you're hedging your bet yeah so which
house do you want that like house or the
one you're at now
honestly i would let moses choose
because i'd probably either want to [ __ ]
up the mayor it's gonna be the water
he wants to be yeah you know what he
said his retirement plan was was to be
lake patrol we saw a lake patrol guy out
there the other day he's like that's
what i want to do when i retire i was
like all right go be the lake patrol and
he was being dead seriously listen
listen
if you guys are buying property though
then i'm happy because that's
that's a good thing for your money i
know you you're taking care of yourself
you've got something you know what i
mean tangible
assets i like that we're also going to
the maldives at a hotel that's fifty
thousand dollars per night
for your and for your honeymoon yeah
it's like a seven day trip is that the
one that's like
underwater oh that's be so sick i'm so
excited
it's gonna be so exciting you're gonna
make bad ass tick tocks there oh
that's all i'm thinking about like
honestly it's gonna be awesome even the
wedding there's always those weddings i
actually want to go there that looks
like so cool i'm not so cool
to be peace and loved about it though i
don't think i could ever spend fifty
thousand dollars a night on a hotel room
it's worth it
it looks amazing but that's just my
peace and love
you should try it the most i've ever
spent on a hotel room was like
uh 3 500 at night which one was it
waldorf no no no that was even close the
one in uh there's a
and yeah post ranch in big sur oh yeah
yeah really beautiful so nice yeah did
you get the house
were you in the house yeah the one right
on the cliff side yeah we almost had the
same
i love how they bring the wood they
bring what i had like the wood burning
the whole time and they just keep
breaking
that's what well i just well i used all
the fireworks
oh yeah it was cold yeah that was the
last time i did drugs i tried we tried
to do molly and i was so sick i was like
on his birthday i was like wow this is
awful oh really yeah
i don't know what's wrong with me i
can't do drugs anymore which is good
honestly i've been sober since december
so
yeah i mean look if you're trying to if
you're trying to have a good stable
situation drugs are will always make it
worse in my opinion
recreational drugs yeah i use that
phonon even alcohol
the only thing with the post ranch was
the food was so small it was so small i
was so hungry
oh get more i'll take two uh
hey i'd like the steak with potatoes uh
two of those please
how many people will be dining with you
one one just myself i know when we
ordered takeout they always bring like
help like 12 spoons like they always
think we're ordering so many
that hotel is so cool though that was
really fun that's a dope one i kind of
look like um a killer like i feel like
i'm hiding out from the world in this
cast
and your barbie cap i feel like i just
committed a crime who's that barbie
killer what is that jody arias you
remember her
she like stabbed her boyfriend 48 times
but she was like really cute well is
this you hearing this [ __ ]
she's idolizing some barbie killer no
i'm not she got a boathouse all lined up
for you
she's got my plans so okay so
here okay no but like honestly when you
stop like thinking about money you just
make more money that's my advice to
people who need money
like stop thinking about it and then
you'll get it when i stop
i don't know i don't know if that i
think that's a privilege to
i think when you're rich then maybe no i
used to be poor i never write and it
wasn't rich my whole life like i feel
like i was poor and then when you stop
thinking about it it just kind of comes
i think i stopped thinking about money
once i started making a lot of money
um mm-hmm yeah and it came no
yeah okay it still kept coming in right
you stopped stressing about it so it
kept coming in well i'm working
i mean i'm working i work too i'm a
hustler
i know dude hey nobody questioned that
you're a hustler all right so here porn
for seven months to keep this you know
like
oh i can i can make say something in the
okay about my porn is it bad
no no no okay in the bus ride home the
party bus ride home oh my god why are
you bringing this up i know what you're
gonna say don't even bring it up it's so
awkward oh i should have so awkward
well now people are gonna watch oh it
was
i didn't think i was such a faux pas
it's like that tic-tac where people do
the
you know you know like i didn't think it
was such a faux pas
i think it was a big one i think you're
there's
go ahead no yeah i don't think you can
say whatever you want i have nothing
else to say about it
i'm gonna tell the story oh people have
but we've talked
yeah but but okay let me at least
explain myself
now let me at least explain myself okay
we're on the party bus and i we all got
our own pizzas
i had my you know i love the pineapple
uh
uh black olive uh
are you okay what is happening with you
i'm slow today
pineapple black olive jalapeno and i had
like three slices i was full
nobody else wanted it so i started
picking the cheese off
okay and i was just eating the toppings
and the pizza looked like a burn victim
it was all disgusting
i don't know if you can make that joke
in 2021 why it's insensitive to burn
i think that's a good analogy it's a
powerful image um
okay maybe just look like like a fresh
burn victim not like a healed burn
ah don't cancel us
when you had that lawsuit i was like
damn we're all going down now you're the
leader of the ship
and i don't want to think with it we're
a duo and we can't have bad
okay whatever apologies to the to the
freshly burned out there stop
oh my god
so anyway you looked at you're like that
is so disgusting i can't look at it like
that's just the grossest thing i've ever
seen that was really gross i
i physically had to lay down after it
and i said i said trisha
who are you to talk about gross throwing
things you've shoved a candlestick up
your ass
uh-huh you didn't say that yeah but okay
so now let me clarify because your mom
and sister were there but everyone
looked at me like
oh my god ethan like everybody it wasn't
even that you kept going
you actually were like you said to my
mom and sister you're like oh you guys
don't know about the candlestick up her
ass story and i was like
well like we don't talk about that oh
maybe that was when i took it too far
yeah but the reason i said it is because
they literally
know everything about this show why
would i which means that i'm
i know that they get know the meaning
that's something they want to talk about
or you want to bring it up
in front of you but like well they were
looking at me like ugh
okay maybe i [ __ ] up but they were
but i only said it because they're so
familiar with everything they d
you do by the way they're your biggest
fans which is really nice
but like that's a meme on the show like
the candlestick up the butt thing right
yeah but it's like they don't
focus on that parents and sisters don't
listen to that kind of thing they like
hear it and it goes out one ear and they
don't like focus and dwell on it like
you do
i thought you guys were all open and
stuff you guys are like all open
not about that oh my god we're not that
open damn go ahead moses got the mic
like he wants to say he's just saying
it's like when they find cigarettes in
your pocket
and they don't believe that you smoke
when they find a candlestick up of your
butt
they don't protect it's not hers yeah
it's not your candles wait what i don't
get i don't get that i know what he's
saying it's it's the it's the parental
yeah it's uh the denial parental denial
i don't think it's that i think it's
just like who wants to talk about that
like i wasn't trying to make it i wasn't
trying to turn it into a topical
conversation i was just making a joke
and everyone looked at me like but you
didn't because you didn't like let it go
because then you like brought it up
again and we're like okay
i only said it i don't know about that
no no no no
okay i didn't mean it like that i only
responded because everyone was looking
at me like i [ __ ] up and i was like
what did i do you all know about the
story because you all watch the show
yeah it's like the first and last time
we hang out as a family oh stop we hung
out
next night well separately with other
people there
why they love me uh yeah did they say
anything about it afterwards
no they didn't and they didn't they like
they didn't like you a lot they think
you're funny
and they were like i won't bring it up
again and they like gila better
me too they're like he was so sweet we
love her and
kyle's like i told her i can't wait to
be related to her but she didn't say
that about you so i don't know
well that's fine i like i i feel the
same way
yeah but you think that it's because of
the candle story i don't know if
that's the reason did i do something
else wrong no
i don't think so oh i think you're just
not as like
warm like hilah gave everyone hugs and
you just like waved at the end because i
thought we were doing kovitz
we all got vaccinated and there were six
of us i would have hugged them
on normal circumstance but like it's
kovid so it's like you're fist bumping
some people
i still feel weird handshaking people
i would have hugged them were they upset
that they didn't they weren't but
it's you you live with gila so she
hugged them so you're going to get the
same
i know it's listen it's a weird
situation it's a world world we're
living in well i know maybe you're just
weird
are you weird with touch which is
totally fine no i i before covet i'll
hug everybody
yeah i'll even get one of these
yeah yeah for sure for sure they really
liked you yeah
yeah okay well anyway
anyway that was an awkward moment that
we shared on the bus
it was great i never seen you look at me
like that before
well you were going through a lot then
too so it's fine
oh yeah just got a lawsuit that's true
but it was
it i mean i was just saying have a good
damn
so are we clear of that now lawsuit are
we clear oh dude because i got put in
that too because
i was on i would stay next to you
they're not suing you though
well i feel like my association the h3
podcast channel i'm a part of um
am i just an employee okay cool yeah
you're just all the employees are
i would say you're a you're not
necessarily employee you're a uh
i think i'm an employee because you like
pay me yeah but you're not
an employee it means you're like on
salary or something you're a contractor
or something independent contractor yeah
yeah yeah oh even better i'm further
away yeah you have no
liability okay i'm gonna say that yeah
yeah everyone's coming from me everyone
was just like
oh like this is the end of them this is
the end of the duas i didn't do anything
don't come for me oh people are still
well
because keemstar was like tap dancing on
twitter about how i'm going to jail and
i have to pay 150 billion dollars as an
outsider when i'm not involved in it i
was kind of like ooh you're getting all
this publicity i was kind of jealous you
were like
thumbnail of philip defranco i've drama
i was like hello okay
bestie well anyway the lawsuit is
totally ridiculous and keemstar is of
course as usual
complete [ __ ] idiot um interestingly
too he he admitted that he's the one
that knarked
to triller slash jake paul he when did
he say that he said that on some
podcasts he did or some one of his
friends said that he said it
i'm gonna talk about it on friday cause
i don't i don't want to necessarily
involve you and all that
but i can pull it up if you no it's okay
let's just talk about disney and my
candlestick
but anyway the lost so here's what's
going on with the lawsuit
trailer jake paul is suing me because um
they are oh yeah i'm being nice i'm
being nice
we're being nice for now because we're
trying to resolve it mediation can i
donate to trailer maybe if i donate on
your behalf to let it go maybe i don't
even i was like what you're trying to
fund their legal offense against me
can we get a legal defense sub for
triller wait what if i like what if i
like go and like pay them or something
can i get it get you off of it
well we're working on that uh oh yeah
we're taking care of that trailer we
stand you hardcore love you
no i'm not saying that okay i'm just not
saying anything right now me too
i'll play the fifth yeah plead the fifth
if i get up on that stand though i'd
defend you
you'd be like your honor he told me
behind the stages
you bring in the receipts you like dunk
on me no no i'll just be like it's a pac
no i'll defend you i'll just be like you
know what we just like exaggerate we're
just you know
crazy like crazy things well i'm
surprised they even brought the clip of
us talking about well
okay whatever i'm not going to say too
i'm not going to say i'm not saying
anything they said
you think it's true everyone says russia
will be the downfall but then they're
like ethan's gonna come from the back
because something will happen with him
so they predicted that when
can we stop with that i know right we're
manifesting positivity that's because
it's like
the psych you know that's the thing with
psychic predictions like is it real now
no no not yet
oh that's it no no no no oh is that the
real one oh
that's it you know you want me to
manifest something good for you yes okay
um you are going to flourish so hard
and you're going to be on one punch man
i'm going to be on an animated yeah
japanese anime yeah you're gonna be a
character on there free that's what i'm
manifesting for you
whoa yeah it's literally impossible
i found that out about you this weekend
that you love one punch man and i was
like i'm gonna get you on that
okay thank you for the manifestation i'm
so excited for you if that happens
if i get up on the japanese manga slash
anime yeah then i will believe in
manifestation really i got it i got
those powers like that
i manifested someone's house like can
you manifest me that i get this house
that i put it off before and i got it
for them
yeah but like do you see they already
put in the offer so it was like already
pretty likely to happen
not necessarily i just gave them extra
powers some might call it prayer
prayer joel osteen
okay so anyway let me just so the
lawsuit
jake paul and triller are well i'm
assuming
it has to do with jake paul because he's
but hurt that i've been talking about
his
incredible allegations from the new
he's been accused of rape okay well he
did get punched in the face
maybe karma he also got punched in the
face but anyway
they're suing me and a bunch of other
people for ripping off the stream
of the fight like you know there's these
websites where you can illegally watch
the fight they just stream it
so there's a bunch of websites like that
and they include me in the lawsuit i was
like i'm sorry i didn't re-broadcast
your stupid [ __ ] fight i just talked
about it right
and what i talked about was completely
fair use by the way and by the way if
you need a reminder i'm the only person
in youtube history
has successfully fought a fair use
battle in one
and let me also remind you that if we do
go to litigation
that my previous win will be used as
precedent in my second battle
and you're rich you can go toe-to-toe
all day long
i mean i'm sure triller has more money
than me but i don't think you need like
i wanted to go to jail with the comedian
that was suing me because i know i have
more money than him i was like let's
do this yeah you don't want to get into
it i was in the right on that one though
i am allowed to talk about whoever i
want to talk about like i can have an
opinion
what was that dude are you not allowed
to talk no i well i don't want to
because they're like crazy but like they
dropped it but they were so like we're
going to write a letter shield or
something here's my lord's information
and then
my lawyer charged me 600 to receive this
letter that they sent them and then
they're they like dropped it uh you got
a flight as [ __ ]
that's right the last lawsuit i've gone
to cost me like 200 thousand dollars
damn bougie it's not boo sad
i should be a lawyer man i'd make so
much money but anyway
um this lawsuit because their lawyer is
like
really bad interestingly they hired like
a really
weird bad lawyer he tried to
first he sued us and he put us with like
20
other defendants and he alleged that we
were in conspiracy with all these
illegal websites
oh so right off the bat and the judge is
like this is an illegal this is a
improper a jointer and throughout the
case
except for one defendant but they can
re-sue me and which is what they're
saying they're gonna do
i might have to go pee is that okay
yeah only if you don't care about my
story so okay but i have to go
go ahead are we like we can go it's not
go ahead are you going to continue when
i'm here or your country yeah we'll cut
it
so now that princess tricia has peed in
the middle of my mind you also peed i'm
kidding you took a pee break
i'm kidding but anyway so the lawsuit is
uh
it's been dropped but they're
threatening to sue me individually it's
the technicality
you know so we're trying to figure out
mediation but i can promise you that i
am not going to jail
as keemstar has been promising which is
just hilarious
yeah he's trying to manifest maybe
oh no don't you dare you won't do his
manifesto okay okay
i manifest you um going
to snl to host but does that counteract
keemstar yes
okay i manifest no because if he can
manifest me in jail and you can manifest
i manifest you free as a bird
i see you flying for whatever forever
that sounds like i'm dying
oh [ __ ] okay i manifest you just sitting
on your couch
forever forever you don't have to leave
your couch sounds lazy
can you just manifest me just unmanifest
keemstar
i can't do on me
[Music]
witchcraft is uh complicated witchcraft
it's like prayer
it's like an anti-curse okay i'm going
you can't prayer something bad on
somebody though that means you'll get
bad karma if you wish something bad on
someone it comes back
you can't manifest bad things so what's
gonna happen it's gonna be boomerang
effect he made it like the rubber and
glue
he's gonna go to prison because he
manifests that for you so it's gonna
backfire
own him it's rubber and glue theory it
does happen yeah for sure
i'm rubber you're glue anything yeah
bounce off you oh
keemstar you just got hit by the rope
and moses is nodding yep that's that
word
like my thing that's just the universe
go ahead wait moses you have insight on
this
yeah if you wish somebody something bad
it comes back to you that's the evil eye
thing right it's the worst thing you can
do
maybe you should get an evil i get a
necklace keemstar and ward off the
energy because you brought it onto
yourself not me
well no i don't want to hmm so if i say
no keemstar don't get the evil eye am i
wishing bad on him
he should get the evil eye because it's
going to come back on him because of
karma if he needs it it won't come to
you it's going to come to him so he
needs to go get it so he like erases
that
but what so if i say no keemstar don't
get the evil eye so you receive all the
negative energies don't say that oh so
that's bad
now i need evil just wish him well be
like good luck
good luck keemstar you're going to need
it oh
oh that's what you said about it yeah
okay all right throwback yeah throwback
okay so here we are singing this is like
the biggest
detour ever i can't show much because it
gets copyrighted but
here we go we're saying you look great
you guys look like you're at the
copacabana
i'm sober oh we sang the love of my life
and we were so good by the way it got
claimed
love of my life here let me just get to
the middle
and then who uploaded this
okay we got claimed i feel like that's
all it takes we'll tell
anyway we'll tell i mean we'll we'll
hopefully be able to tell if it gets
claimed or not
i can play without sound what it means
to me
i put it up there oh love of
my life and then i said okay eli you get
out of this yeah what happened there
you're just like okay i'm gonna go do a
solo one now bye
i was like now listen i got i says
trisha i know she's the big girl tonight
big i was like literally you should just
do the sides
i thought i meant you're the song okay i
didn't mean that way i meant she
could say birthday i said she's
you can see what i say hopefully in the
beginning if moses included it
did you get that part we'll find it so
let's see
whoops you're like living your best life
look at you you look great oh i'm not
it's not on the screen idiot ethan dumb
ass
no don't don't say those bad things
about yourself
i think it's funny when i put myself
down and people get really they get
really worried about me
oh i know i hate when people do that too
when i'm just like i say oh yeah my
music [ __ ] i had someone be like don't
say that don't say about yourself it's
like a dope like i'm just
obviously putting money into my music
yeah i'm having fun it's more like
setting your expectations low for people
so i don't think you're like you know
i don't know for me i think it's funny
when i make like a minor [ __ ] up and
they go
idiot [ __ ] i hate myself right i just
find it funny
for myself i guess to overreact like
that and people get really worried
but anyway here it is i was worried
about you at the beginning of that
remember getting in front of me and i
was like i
feel like you're gonna die soon i don't
feel that way anymore
that's bad manifestation no i don't feel
that way anymore yeah but you manifested
it back then
but it didn't work you were trying to
kill me no but i thought about it i saw
it in my dreams and i was like [ __ ]
remember i was worried about you i was
like but who says it's not gonna happen
it's not
i see only like positive i see like you
know what i see in my dreams i see
you're like dressed in like glittering
gold cape
for real kind of like pocahontas you
remember when the guy comes to like
mine you know he's like in a gold
glittering cape his name's radcliffe
pocahontas was he one of the colonizers
he was but i see you in that cape not
you're not a colonizer no no no no no
you're in that group i'm a genocide a
mass murderer no you're in a gold
sparkly cape in my dreams
okay that sounds good okay that's pretty
epic thank you like chat like elton john
or cha
or what's his name ellen john or who's
the tchotchke
liberace i think more alan john you're
more of an alan john i love elton john
i don't he seems so mean he seems like
an [ __ ] he's genuine
no people say he's mean look it up i
don't care if i don't care what he is i
love elton john's music
i i think he's the best i don't think
his music's not good either i went to a
concert and i was like
stop like the alligator croc or rock or
whatever it is it's bad
okay that's like first of all that
song's good second of all that's like
one of like a billion hit songs he has i
like the queen movie better than the
ellen john movie
i don't even know the result in general
movie really it came out right after
that's what i'm saying i don't watch the
biopics they're too they gotta chill
with the biopics
he married a woman did you know that
elton john
he was married to a woman like at the
height of his fame oh
before he was out i mean i think he was
out i think he just
the man the person who was sleeping with
the manager was like you need to like
marry a woman
so he did that oh
anything else i guess alan john's not
coming on the show after all right let's
see if i called you fat or not in the
beginning you didn't want me fast
how could you listen it's important
well i told him i told him when i came
up i was like yo can i do two i want to
do one with my wife
and then one for my wife oh you did tell
them yeah you have vip treatment well
well what like you said it wasn't like
and it wasn't like everyone was waiting
i kept seeing like your
people the same people doing it over and
over again yeah so it's like it's not
like there's like a huge
line so i didn't think anyone cared i
don't know no it was cool i was like
okay
so anyway by yourself that's what i
would do okay
the one girl who's always number one in
my heart wait what did i say just to
make sure i didn't call you fat
you didn't call me fat i didn't you
probably fat here you just called me
it's important i know it's all
i know it's all about tristan's night
but this one's gotta go out to the one
girl who's always number one in my heart
it's my beautiful wife oh the crap
that was so cute i'm embarrassed now
so i can't play this it's uh not my
tic-tac
spend my day yeah that was weird
it was a good choice it was a different
choice why al green you don't like the
song how come you did that voice it was
a different voice than you used for love
of my life
because that's how al green sings
okay like foster you're doing like an
impersonation yeah
okay i thought maybe you'd make it your
own being next to you
okay being close to you i can't
explain myself
it sounds just like yeah you were i was
i thought it was supposed to be funny
are you trying to be funny though i mean
i know i'm not a good singer if that's
what you know
but you are a good singer oh is he like
trying to go for like impersonation or
is he trying to go for funny
i was just having a good time up there
oh you were well that's good you weren't
well
i don't know listen give me a break you
seem like yes i was embarrassed
you weren't while you were doing this i
literally just did this so that you
would let leave me with the party
people were living for it they loved it
i loved it that was the best that was
the highlight of the night
i threw my hat i tried to throw my hat
to ila and i ended up hitting some dude
not paying attention it was drinking
yeah i think it's right here wait let me
see
i think it's coming up and let you know
that love is really real when i got when
i said we looked at the house i saw the
stage and i was like um karaoke for sure
there
dude that was so yeah it was so perfect
for the
karaoke it's like did anyone ever jump
in the pool
no oh that's i know i was hoping someone
would it would be so great
i'm just i'm waiting for the hat throw
it's coming
oh i think you hit i know your mom and
scissors so funny
you loving me but it seems to me
okay i was trying to hit all the high
notes oh my god you were really killing
it
[Music]
at my wedding why not you i'll get drunk
at your wedding for sure
why why am i wedding and not here just
because it's like later in the year
i'll plan for it this was like when you
invited me like one day before you're
like oh i guess it's so natural
like i didn't really want to buy it i
gave you a week
i'll see you guys live too far away i'm
gonna be honest so i hit through the hat
and it hit this poor guy he wasn't
paying attention
yeah there he was just drinking minding
his own business
yeah okay ah that was so cute yeah it
was fun
good time and then i i stage dove and
crushed a bunch of people
i want to stage knife so bad can we do
that as a competition like rock star day
like we just dive into a crowd or
something so like because i feel like
you're
really good see who falls through let's
see who can
cry because i've seen people like dj
khaled stutt
stage dive and he just hit he sinks like
a [ __ ] rock
really oh yeah cause that's scared i
would do it though
i give it a shot okay so let's try and
because you just have to gently
glide up cause some people are like
let's go like dj khaled it's like
you hit the ground sure let's do it okay
i'm down
all right um somebody made a meme about
your character development on the show i
think i have some stuff to show you that
i think you'll enjoy
from the subreddit oh okay this was a
kind of a complicated meaning i don't
get this at all i hate these character
things well hold on did you read it yet
well i just automatically see people
that i don't know who that what's it
from like it just looks like you don't
know
uh uh uh avengers never said
no okay well it should still make sense
well i'm surprised you missed thanos
that's kind of a big deal don't know who
that is
so someone said rip trisha's phone case
did trisha
have character development yes okay
what did it cost adam sandler i don't
understand at all so in the movie
so in the movie she says uh something
what did she ask him uh it's just like
did you get what you
tried did you get what you wanted yes
whatever and she said what did it cost
you
everything that's what he says in the
movie yeah sounds cheesy
extremely so that's what it's supposed
to be those kind of movies i thought
those movies were like yeah everyone's
like these are
cool no it was a good but it's true it
wasn't easy can still be fun but yeah
it's definitely cheesy okay wow i'm not
here to hate on uh end game well why
adam sandler it didn't cost me adam
sandler i still love him
you ditched him you freaking ditched him
during that show
why what what happened why did i kill
you you said i was talking about how
much i hate i think his movies suck and
then you're like okay i think i'm out
and i am sandler you forget last week
yeah okay kind of so i guess that meme
doesn't work
when you can't remember seven days ago i
made a meme the other day but i don't
know
okay and then here's the my james
charles update
um so he was
he sent this guy a threatening he's
still threatening people
man you know what do you say let's find
out
oh my gosh he's dead no
i guess muted tan okay here it is
so he said here let's see if i can zoom
i wish it showed the date he said hi can
you please remove your tick
tock of me if you don't then my legal
team will be in contact with you
thank you not that [ __ ] again
my legal team will be there they don't
know that's not happening can i tell you
guys a tip
when someone's actually going to see you
they don't [ __ ] message you
i hate this is like the fifth influencer
i've seen this week like threatening
these like young kids to be like oh
shameless
legal team will be in contact no they're
not it is so
embarrassing so shameless and so
so dumb so dumb don't ever believe
anyone also you can post whatever you
want on tik tok as long as you're not
like hurting somebody or yourself
uh excuse me my legal can you remove
that tick tock of me i wonder what it
was i want to watch it now
people can make straight up lies about
you and they still can't see you like
i've had people like make up the crazy
about me and i like you still get my
lawyers like you can't really see it's
like you have to prove damages
exactly it's so so hard yeah because
like um
yeah people if sure like the thing is
defamation and slander lawsuits
are really used
yeah you have to prove damages so let's
say like the new york times prince and
goes
oh ethan uh is a murderer okay whatever
yeah and i go oh
and then i start losing work right right
but then i have like a real defamation
lawsuit right for my losses
but you have to prove monetary damage
it's so hard so james charles is going
to let these people bully your
nobody's suing some random tick talker
that has never happened
ever never it's not going to happen i
was threatened with a lawsuit by some
old ass comedian for doing a tick tock
saying i think
i can't say his name i was the same guy
you mentioned yeah but it's like
that's why that's what i was like sue me
oh i know who you're talking about yeah
i was like what it's stupid oh i saw
your video it wasn't even anything
defamatory you're like he's creepy weird
yeah i was like sue me i would love it
but you removed it
no you didn't no it's still up oh you
didn't remember oh
i can see what you want on tick tock if
someone's a public figure you can give
an opinion about someone damn
right you can't say this happened you
know that right
yeah i mean like lying i guess but even
these kids who just like there was one
influencer someone did they had a
picture and her whole account is like
why don't you say who it is you didn't
take it down this is not not worth it
you don't want to push it well because i
already paid 600
just to accept a letter from this lawyer
and then they never went anywhere so i
was just like okay but um
there there's one influencer or there's
like a tick-tock page and she has a ton
of pictures from vidcon with
influencers and her thing is she shows
the picture and she makes up a complete
story about like how they were [ __ ]
or something like that but they weren't
but
what is it a joke does she yeah yeah
yeah does it to everyone so she has like
shane davis that's
not illegal yeah but then one of the
influencers i'm not going to mention
this person but they were they like
reach out to her and said the same thing
like my legal team is going to contact
you so embarrassing
but even in that case without a lie and
it's like slander no it's not
that is legal because it's obviously
parody
based on her track record but then she
showed the dms and she's like not taking
it down
so yeah good for her yeah so anyways
don't let people bully you
especially if you're like a minor like
don't give people your information i've
seen influencers be like
give me your parents address i'm gonna
sue you don't do that like they don't
need they're
that's not how it works and like i said
if somebody really gonna sue you they're
not gonna send you a message saying
uh you have to remove this or i'm gonna
sue you that's them being cheap because
they can't even
send a seat assist so they're extremely
cheap and by the way anytime someone
refers to their legal team they're full
of [ __ ] yeah
there's no legal i send you oh that's
good
hopefully hopefully i'll be getting a
hold of blue james legal team now
it's so mild i'm not i i'm so confused
why he would oh that's awesome
i love james being such a petty little
[ __ ] a friend of mine said james charles
wanted to call and
this is it um this is before and after
and i'm also going to show you
this pretty sunset picture this is it
the balcony was in the way it was so
annoying
i wanted to get rid of it you can also
erase people oh they're photoshopping
them out um oh cause it's just a joke
about james charles being the worst
any picture i use this on so many of my
photos they they photoshopped him out oh
this is
what this is what he's got that's
actually pretty impressive photoshopping
though it was so annoying
um i wanted to get rid of it you can
also erase people which is amazing
it's a joke about erasing james charles
he's anything from anyone
wow what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is his life and he has time to like
look at this stuff and like well he's
got a lot of time now he ain't doing
[ __ ]
what a [ __ ] loser
james charles is my least favorite
person in the um
i mean on youtube oh yes oh well no
keemstar's probably
well i don't know okay i mean it's it's
tough but they're both
pretty i mean yeah keemstar is the worst
i won't i won't but james charles i
can't even mention who the worst person
on the internet is i can't don't even
i think i know you know but yeah yeah
but yeah
oh my but i can't get over what a petty
little [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he is
yeah james charles erase you let's all
erase james charles i love the message
of this
hi my what what exactly is your legal
claim james charles
what exactly is your legal team going to
be saying in the letter
this is so like can you imagine hi it's
come to my attention
that you uh took a photo of james
charles and erased him this
we consider uh defamatory
no copyright infringement no it's a co
is it a copyrighted photo
no people are so stupid it's a loser
yeah oh my god i always say this you
know who has legal teams
disney you know who doesn't have legal
teams any influencer
oh should i talk about i got an apology
or no is that what we're talking about
oh yeah because it's coming up it'll
come up next oh you have it okay
yeah i was gonna bring it up stay tuned
for the apology
and then there's another james charles
cartoon that i thought was funny james
charles uh i'm waiting to hear from your
legal team
hey sister i love the hair
the hair is so good oh yeah he has this
tape over the teddy fresh i got you a
spring chicken burrito hey that's my job
oh hey james let me slip into something
more comfortable
[Music]
so good
[Music]
hello james why don't you take a seat
oh no oh my god oh my god yo who made
this
i don't know they gave you credit for
the idea though okay that's nice shout
out to them but who
is it wait it says it right there under
underneath uh
full credit too here i want to make sure
this guy gets credit
on youtube yeah and all this i love that
oh that's a lot of views good for him um
mighty davilio mighty devi
leo yeah shout out to you i'm gonna link
let's link him in the description
okay i'll make a note mighty deleon me
in the description
um you're literally always the top you
are
always at the top of every description
at
trisha paytas your youtube channel
or blonde sundol yeah as i i might
youtube channels not to sharpen it well
whatever your [ __ ] channel is oh my
god you don't even know my channel
well it's like a weird name juan sun
doll for mj thank you well dan's the one
that writes it so
oh he knows okay i trust you you want to
see how
[ __ ] prominently we list it do you
really i actually have no idea
yeah every time dude here here's like
the second episode you made a comment
about it and really
did it like me yeah and i was like well
you're right i should skinny legend
there
okay why is that so skinny they got his
hair though oh yeah i think it's the
hair
god i look good there
we have to put the sponsors first but
right after that okay wait wait wait
wait
wait you rather get paid everybody knows
who you are you just like trisha payton
no i got more subscribers because you
guys are doing that because i'm like why
isn't my subscribers going up i was
always at 4.9 for like literally seven
years
well it's from yeah friend of mine but
now i'm at 5.1 i know it's awesome your
channel is going it's great
yeah here look at this trisha's
youtube damn become a member here
wow trisha's channel everyone go
subscribe
[Applause]
yeah that's me that's cool yeah go
subscribe i eat
that's my pitch
so james charles that's good times
and then oh here's another little james
charles update you might enjoy
i don't enjoy any james charles update
you might enjoy this one i don't like
him i hate i really
okay morphy puts him on sale
finally but wait till you see how much
okay morphe puts james charles palette
on sale on their website
four dollars off okay you like that yeah
i mean a sale is anything yeah that's
significant it's just like [ __ ]
35 35 still a lot exactly wait to see
one of these ones
okay five let's use credits from numbers
they're six dollars
we should cancel morphy they're so
problematic like let's put them on the
list to cancel
bro this literally this is like i just i
can't get over there still selling a
[ __ ]
the fact that they're just like they're
so what is the word like tone deaf where
they just don't understand like okay
you're gonna like to pull everyone
else's pal but you're gonna keep james
charles up there like you're
i don't think they're tom i don't know i
don't think so i don't think he's toned
up i think they just have like millions
of dollars of his [ __ ] that they
are don't know a major l on you're gonna
take an l on it if you want to like see
what i'm saying you could sell to ross
or some dumbass thing and like cut your
costs
cut your losses and then this one you
get a whopping two dollar discount
it's better than nothing i guess don't
buy this palette if you're out there
it's [ __ ]
morphe products are [ __ ] i bought one
the other day so seriously i bought a
palette so serious i was trying to be
like madison beer did a makeup tutorial
she has a palette with morphe so i
bought it and i was like okay i'm going
to be a madison beer makeup like i
genuinely wanted to like look like her
it was the shittiest palette ever like
chalk it's literally chalk it makes
sense they're just trying to
cash like i bought it myself i wanted to
whatever i was like i really wanted to
look like madison beer in her vogue
makeup tutorial and i like got the
palette and i was like this is the
shittiest palette i've ever used
yeah because it because it's like you're
cut when you're doing collabing with the
influencer it's like you're cutting
up the profits they're just trying to
make as much money as possible the
frenemies palette is not gonna be [ __ ]
we are working with the best of them we
are
making a palette i didn't know that i'm
working on it
we're working on it are you really i
don't know i'm manifesting it
we could probably do it i mean yeah i
didn't know that that was something we
wanted to do what do we name the colors
like
here let me talk to our production team
and see if we can
alfredo alfredo white
shredder brown dominoes domino's
pepperoni uh rep pink
dan what's dan's color what's color your
beard dan whatever that color is brown
sure yeah people like dan's with blue
eyes
yeah okay blue so blue for dance dance
beautiful blues
which has to compete with hila blue yeah
you can true yeah
there's two blue okay let's see if we
can make that i don't know if that's
like complicated though to make
we want to have a good one though too i
hate putting like [ __ ] cuz like the
merch is such good quality that's like
we can't have like [ __ ] product well
i'll see what we can do i'll talk to the
teddy fresh team and see if that's
something we can source
i love that but obviously i won't put
anything bad that's what we made teddy
fresh because all their
influencer merch is like you can't do
anything fun or interesting yeah
it's super cheap and it's all just about
making money yeah you're gonna study
fresh is like
i'm very excited for our frenemies yeah
it's gonna slap it's gonna be the best
my goal my dream too is like if this
first drop does well which i think it
will you know
our next one i want us to get more
creative like we can have a design
session me and you
and actually make like embroideries and
patches and art
and make something like a real
collection that's not just merch but
like
we're like streetwear yes exactly actual
streetwear i mean
well the friendly stuff is kind of
streetwear like the silhouettes
yeah they're cool but like i think we
could do something really creative and
interesting i'm excited
yeah i love how i got in there like i
found my way into the teddy fresh world
i'm still honored because remember the
first the first time i met you on the
podcast i was like you guys should like
do this for like other influencers and
you're like no because it was like you
know you're so like you just want to do
your own thing but i was like i got in
there because i wanted to be one of
those people that you did that for now
and i'm in
i don't know how well women yeah i don't
want to do it for other influencers
because it's like
first of all we're all super [ __ ]
busy making our own [ __ ] yeah we could
help people find people but i know what
you're saying but
that's what i was saying the first time
and you're just like no busy i don't
yeah we don't want to
over i'm not interested in working with
influencers that's just that's a whole
dumb stupid market yeah but for us we're
gonna go all out
i love it i think i snuck into this
world somehow we'll remember when we
were
snucking through the back i was like the
back door through moses moses is the
back door
you know um at first you thought i
wasn't even going to pay you
i know damn i got paid
got paid yet but maybe i'll get paid i'm
yeah you always pay me
thank you of course i do all right so
now
it's like yeah we make so much money now
you have to delay the payment you're
like now i gotta wait a couple weeks oh
yeah so i think that's everything that's
bougie that's cool you were on it though
i paid right on the 15th i was like
yeah you know we're serious i check my
bank account every day because i'm
always scared i'm gonna get hacked so i
chuck it every single morning so when i
saw it in there
i checked my bank account every morning
like because why do you do that right no
okay i must be the only one because
everyone's like you check it for a while
i always think like my bank account is
getting hacked or something oh you're
afraid
well don't you have like a cpa looking
through your [ __ ] or any any kind of
finance yeah i
do i guess i just like always i'm
worried like someone's taking stuff i
don't know i just i check it every day
i'm like a crazy like as soon as i wake
up
i check i go through our finances a lot
because that's just something i do yeah
but i don't check it like first thing in
the morning where i can wake up in the
sweat and i'm like oh [ __ ] let me know
i do that it's so weird no i don't do
that make sure everything's
like i have multiple the thing is our
bank accounts are pretty secure like
mine is too because i get like
notifications and stuff like that but
like i don't know it's just so weird
anyways so i check it every morning and
then on that 15th or 16th
wow do you ever see anything weird yeah
yeah like sometimes i'll be i don't
recognize things so
yeah you know i check it out
good for you gotta check your money keep
your mind on your money and your money
on your mind right
that's so weird this is so weird um so
uh bryce there's one little bryce hall
thing and then we'll talk about scotty
sayer
right oh well he was our previous
douchebag of the month last month so i'm
doing a little update you should go
through your dms and show all the
celebrities that you missed dming you
and bryce hall was one of them
did this tick tock where he's like yo i
didn't realize you could that there's
like unsolicited
messages from verified accounts here and
he's like i've been ignoring all these
people for years
and i was like oh [ __ ] me too and then
you went to go live and then i looked
and there's all these verified people
pop one was it bryce yeah bryce was well
he was the most recent like really big
account
he messaged me being like yo i want to
come on your show and i was like no but
it goes by followers so is he the top
because it goes by what no followers i
think it's about it well
is it general or request no request we
have to
request a request and then verified so i
go top requests
yeah no oh
wait what is all this this isn't that
yeah it is it is here can i see it
that was it
there it is oh so bro no mr beast has
more
oh weird because it's about relevance
mine's not mine goes by followers
wow who are all these people jason nash
messaged me
that did not age well jason messes me
and i didn't respond 92 weeks ago i feel
so
i do feel bad he said hi i appreciate
you
oh i shouldn't show that i feel bad why
write back things i just feel bad
because i did i just ignoring him all
this jason is the one person who hasn't
taken any accountability
i know i don't know just on a human
level i feel bad because
no i just ignore well i ignored
everybody he's a [ __ ] person and until
he apologizes or acknowledges something
that he did
with the wrong which is like literally
forcing someone to kiss i don't know who
most of these people are to be totally
honest with you let me see what we see
here tell me if you know this is so
exciting oh okay hey legend
this is so cool i don't know people love
you
who's that oh my god tattoo why i don't
even have tattoos they want to give you
oh it's in a story
okay this is so fun
do you know all these people oh wait who
do you say
oh okay oh okay sorry
do we say it though that guy's like a
creeper
because i don't want trisha to that
guy's like he's he's a actual p
word okay good i'm closing my phone p3
p3do p3do r23pdo
that's him all right let's move on he's
a tattooer we can see him he's he's
gross he's been put on blast like i
don't want to say anything because i
don't know anything about him and i
but it's facts okay i don't i'm not
going to put someone up
i just let's not i'm not not a p300 they
deserve to be put on blast
i don't know anything about it i
literally never even heard of his name
he admitted to it okay fine let's not
let's just not that's what we
do we have to let people know about sex
offenders i literally don't know
anything about this guy he sent me
unsolicited dm
and now you're ready to [ __ ] like i
hate when people do that kind of dm
though because he was trying to say like
he has issues with someone that you have
issues with
i hate that kind of bonding it's like oh
i also hate this person
yeah i don't like that the enemy of
enemy of my enemy is not always my
friend
enemy and my enemy is not always my
friend of me
is now my friend of me you want to watch
bryce hall be a [ __ ] douche for a
minute no
i don't know it's really cool dude that
guy he's like on steroids or something
i never would never he's so unstable
i just every time i watch him he's so
unstable and mentally just
so unhealthy well we don't want to like
give him a diagnosis of being unstable
maybe he's fine maybe he's trolling
maybe he's
no on wrong nice yeah exactly
oh sorry about that
and then his boyfriend came back and was
like yo you better apologize and he
bitched out and got all
let me see beta let's go oh sorry about
that
youtube [ __ ] that was bad
oh my god oh my god just coming back it
was a joke it was sorry
it was a joke
[Music]
which is funny because he's always the
tough guy in all his clips like flip me
[ __ ]
and i was like you're a little [ __ ]
actually in real life into like a girl
too it's like you're
okay okay so that's it so scotty sire
apparently we call him [ __ ] hall
little [ __ ] [ __ ] you going down the
[ __ ] hall
it's like a hall full of [ __ ] i like
that that's him
okay [ __ ] all he he wants to come on
our show so bad and fight and like try
to like
fight no he wants to cause a scene and
get all tough because he does these
videos where he goes to like his haters
house and be like
come on fight me [ __ ] that's actually
kind of funny though to like
because he wouldn't do anything so
you're just like filming him doing that
and then you're like okay of course he's
not going to do anything but
he's awful i mean he's also just like
going to be irrelevant a year so like
what's the point
i love seeing people come and go i don't
love seeing people come and go but
that's bad manifestation no it's okay to
have entertainment
no that's like entertainment it's not
like i'm wishing manifestation
no maybe he's on to better things after
that tick tock maybe he's gonna become a
doctor or something you know
all right so i was gonna become a doctor
never know i'm manifesting that for him
maybe maybe a dentist he needs to be on
social media but maybe he'll succeed
somewhere else in life like
all right enough about bryce hall [ __ ]
him let's talk about that [ __ ]
sorry [ __ ] scotty sire
so we went in on scotty sayer a little
bit for his apology
uh song promotion last week pretty hard
on him
uh oh this was kind of a good tweet this
was in response to scotty right yeah
you said what what is it that he said
before i read yours
so he was apparently on discord what is
a discord
it's like a private chat room for where
how do you get on we have a chat we have
a discord for our
members where do i go let's find out
you'll never figure it out okay
yeah i'll just i'll just say i'll just
save you that first okay
you'll never figure it out everyone's on
discord okay all right
so he says 60k views on my new video and
no comments
do y'all want me to fail react to this
if you think youtube shadow banned me so
he's like begging his die hard fans to
slam
slam emojis on it yeah cringe for sure
why what is this the most emojied one is
the laughing tongue out which is like
i don't know if that's such a supportive
emoji yeah i was like
[ __ ] you like i just don't think that's
a supportive emoji
i did that emoji on him i went you did
that one
so you quote tweeted and said or maybe
it's him telling victims of sa
which is probably at least 75 percent of
his audience victims of essay
i'm sure about 75 these days like
every single woman has probably
experienced essay or no someone they
haven't seen and with men it's like one
and two they say so
i'm like giving an average i got it got
it got it
so you're telling them how to feel and
how they're supposed to react so anyway
this is
when you came with the real slam dunk
you're like yo scotty sorry about to sit
down take this out
he said i don't know who needs to hear
this but
you're not shadow band just irrelevant
i've been irrelevant at least 15 times
in the past couple years so i know
don't be an [ __ ] then it'll get
better
i mean i think i think i hate my biggest
pet peeve
is when people like hey guys youtube is
pressing my videos shout out it's like
literally like
no literally people if people want to
see your videos they'll go like to your
channel and look for them you know what
i mean
the truth the hard truth you know
the hard truth to take is
i think there are some exceptions where
where this individual videos will get
suppressed for like getting a mature
rating or something
yeah like you say when you do the adam
and eve ones because it gets like mature
rated
but the hard truth to swallow is that
most of the time when that happens
it's because people are not clicking
your videos yeah like so youtube doesn't
show it to people
yeah i don't know why he's shocked i
mean he's been a complete [ __ ] this
year and
tone deaf for sure but also like your
whole videos were just starring david
and now david's not in them so of course
nobody cares about you anymore like it's
not that hard to figure out one plus one
equals three
or two or four whatever the [ __ ] that
saying is one plus one equals
is it saying that it's wrong no go ahead
keep one plus one equals three means
it's wrong one plus
one equals three that's the same i don't
think that's a saying
is that a saying yeah when you're trying
to prove somebody wrong you're like okay
that's like saying one plus one equals
three
okay anyways so anyways it doesn't
surprise me but yeah but this
it's with other people too that are like
guys all the time you hear that
literally nobody cares
all the time youtube showing my video to
my fans it's like well
probably not clicking it and then when
you say it you sound even more pathetic
i'm like okay well even if you are
like they're not searching for you then
people are not seeing your videos they
don't give a [ __ ] like
i search for people i always search for
people if i don't see their videos it's
a hard pill to swallow because you want
to blame
you want to scapegoat youtube and not
blame yourself but
but truthfully you know you gotta fight
to
to stay to keep your vids fresh and keep
get people clicking people are clicking
youtube's
and is going to show people it's the
same with all social media instagram
it is his the problem is his yeah
exactly the problem is his algorithms
are getting correct yes it hasn't posted
in like two months and he's like well
there's no one look at my videos like
yeah and also you literally victim
blamed like everybody that's ever been
assaulted so okay but what happened he
texted you over an apology you said
well i think i was i think it wasn't
even that oh i think it was after that
because we had put the show out
and a lot of people thought i was a
little harsh on scott i don't think i
was harsh actually i don't take it back
i don't think anything back i said i
don't think i was harsh at all but
some people in the comments even our
podcast like i think she went a little
harsh on
scott and then i put out that tweet and
i and like right away
not right away the next day he the day
we went you're going to read his
text why not i'll paraphrase i mean it
was nice right so
it will make him look good right so
i think really a little bit of okay
let's just weigh the pros and cons i'll
do a little i'll just
do a little phrase so i think like
first thing is like apologies do go like
such a long way right when david
dobrik said in his apology video he's
gonna personally apologize to people
that he's hurt or offended i didn't call
you
and didn't call me daddy that was even
more death that i'm aware of
yeah i was like uh that even was more
offensive
so right you know like to even say face
even if scott's doing this to save face
because he knows i'm gonna talk about it
because i have a loud mouth you know and
be like okay that's gonna make me look
like a good person
even that i guess i'll take because i
think it's still pointing yeah i still
want a little bit of like an apology
and it feels like it feels good also but
also scott apologizing is weird cause i
didn't need an apology from him so i
don't really know why he was apologizing
because he was
well i think he felt but i think he felt
like he triggered me i think he just
all around feels bad with how he his
everything he got so
slam dunked by defending and attack
defending david slash
attacking seth yeah hopefully he
apologized to that i mean hopefully he
reached out to him because
honestly i was triggered i guess he was
apologizing for triggering me or
something i don't know
honestly it was sincere like what did he
say he said he goes
should i just read it i don't know okay
can we get a room temp
i don't know is it okay to read okay
i'll paraphrase
okay okay don't read it don't read it
verbatim
i i don't think you would mind because
it's like he's nice he looks good
yeah but maybe it's better to prepare
just paraphrase
stop paraphrase um okay so he did say he
wanted to apologize for triggering i was
trying to figure out what he was trying
to apologize for
yeah like well because i was so angry
and you know what about me is
i get really heated and angry and then i
can if someone that's what i'm saying if
someone apologizes even if it's
insincere it means so much like all i
wanted
was for jason and david to acknowledge
that like what they did with the tana
thing was like
by the way did you see tana commenting
on my tic-tock i made a tick tock saying
like
oh the time david tried to force me and
like my 45 year old boyfriend to have a
threesome with an idea
and then she commented on that she goes
tag yourself she goes i'm the 19 year
old who's in therapy because of this
did you see that so she obviously had
some you know trauma from that too so
anyways and that's all i ever wanted
from them all they ever wanted was like
an acknowledgement like hey
instead they said that i was the problem
and they tried to make me apologize to
brandon the guy that was dating a minor
they just tried to make me
anyways so apology is all i've ever
wanted from them i didn't really need
one from scott but i appreciate it and
i'm the last same thing with jeff when
he apologized
again the sincerity of it i think it's
pretty sincere but you know maybe some
people say they're just doing this to
say face either way i think it's a
you know because he knows i'm going to
say this and then daddy dave is going to
hear this and so daddy is going to know
scott's talking to me and getting like
what the [ __ ] why are you talking to
church so i thought it was a big move
you know because he probably could get
in trouble for talking to me because i'm
freaking i think that
yeah you know that's very caught like
we're like how could you talk to trish
right or apologize for her you're
admitting guilt or whatever the [ __ ]
um but he said i apologize for
triggering you um
he goes i'm ashamed i made the video uh
it was wrong of him he's like admitting
that he's wrong just question seth's
motive
he said he was coming from a biased
perspective um
and he says it took some videos and
commentary from you and others to
realize the magnitude might [ __ ] up
which i think is a big thing too because
people have called me out
i don't realize that sometimes you don't
realize like what you're doing and i
believe that was scott i really do think
he was just trying to give david points
too he was an investor in the app so
he's trying to save face for him it was
i think he was just his
friend he's like yo i love my friend no
he only ever gets disappointed people
it's like he was just so [ __ ]
out of touch i don't know i could just
tell from that video maybe he's never
been a victim of
essay because the way he was just
talking was so insensitive i hope he
feels manipulated by david though
because let's not forget that in
scotty's video david sent him
receipts yeah i think that's it david's
like look i'll show you and then scott's
like okay i'm gonna try he's fired up
he's like oh this is a slam dunk
yeah yeah yeah so um so he said he's
taking
time to reflect um and then he said he
wasn't trying to blame his mental health
because my other issue
is people blaming like mental health and
stuff and saying they're depressed or
whatever and then
did he send you an audio file of his
song the full version no but he did have
a clarification about a song lyric thing
okay
okay good good so after all this he said
um
uh you know he was really nice and then
he goes uh i know
blah blah blah because i know sometimes
i can still be an [ __ ] but this is
what he wanted to clarify to you
he said ethan is this for me yeah oh
hell yeah also so he did this whole
thing he said he was an [ __ ] but you
know
i do accept scott's apology i was just
triggered a little i still thought it
was very insensitive but hey if someone
apologizes like you should try and
forgive them and give them another
chance i think
what did he say about me so you were
confused by the line from his song
that says i live a good life and pretend
that it blows and i was like oh he's
pretending yeah
no you didn't know you were like wait so
he's pretending that his life
i live a good life and pretend it blows
i was like it sounds like someone who's
just like trying to be
act depressed for clown right right
right like he's like faking it and
he didn't he said he goes that was the
second song i wrote and then he goes it
was one it was satire
and then he goes it was poor poor
lyricism he goes but you hit the nail on
the head with what i meant so what i
said he meant
was that people think he has a really
cushioned life but you know even though
he has a christian life he still can be
okay so what his message to me is that
it was poor
lyricism okay thank you and that i was
right about his
did he apologize to me for his poor
therapist apologize for it
um he owes us all an apology for that he
says i know you don't like me
he's like i want an apology anyway which
i thought was you know i take some guts
he seems nice because honestly i mean no
one was still coming for scott except
for me so he really didn't have to do
that you know
that video dude he should be pissed at
david because he was like good
everybody liked him i liked him everyone
big anyone who talked okay we're
we're good with scott now scotty
we're not drawing we're neutral okay
neutral scale thinks david's a good
person so that's
questionable but we'll say neutral did
he say that like in his videos
okay so hey that's cool you know what
david could be a good person to some
people
exactly people it's not like good or bad
people aren't except for keemstar
you know no david's also a [ __ ] person
but i i've never met yeah i'm just
saying like
it's a it's just oversimplifying the
entirety of a human being to say
oh he's a good person always a bad
person you know what i mean because
people are so complex
other than keemstar he is an objectively
like totally
un debatably bad person you don't have
to comment on that
david dobrik is also unobjectively a bad
person
my point is is that scotty thinks he's a
good dude i'm sure some people i'm sure
keemstar's girlfriend thinks he's a good
dude probably not
i'm sure banks thinks he's a good dude
probably not i think he does probably
talk
[ __ ] behind his back guarantee face
blinks
if he does thinks he's a good person
because he has one operating brain cell
no comet phase blinks
that's what i call him did you know that
i know that you tell me that all the
time i love i think that was a really
good nickname i thought price how [ __ ]
hall do you know that
yes that was really good well faze
blinks they he they did a podcast with
keemstar talking about the lawsuit and
then
of course kim starts tap dancing that
i'm gonna owe 150 billion dollars and
i'm gonna go to jail for six months
and then faceblinks goes to be honest
jake paul is a
billion times smarter than ethan wow and
let's just say i'm not going to come out
here and to my horn like i'm the
smartest guy in the world but phase
blanks
let's object let's be objective here
i don't know i'm [ __ ] albert einstein
converted jake paul
we don't know what if jake paul is a
genius
i would say no jake paul probably has
the iq
somewhere around uh let's say a um
you know what's interesting what um
dinosaurs okay oh it's not interesting
okay it's not interesting you're right
okay let's move on do you want to say
your dinosaur fact yeah
so like if you look at like a
brontosaurus was like one of the big
the biggest land mammal that ever walked
earth or close to it
there are these massive creatures
obviously but they're called a
bronchiosaurus
bronchial it's one of the ones with the
huge neck you know and that little
so their brains were so small their
brains were like the size of a
dime so i would say jake paul
is bronchiosaurus level iq what's your
dinosaur ikea
i'm a pterodactyl pterodactyl i don't
know how air i don't know how
aerodynamic you are
i am i can fly there's a new jurassic
world at universal did you go on it yet
no i haven't been to the universe in a
while i want to though i'll take what
are you you're a t-rex you got baby arms
thank you good analogy thank you
baby-handed t-rex
you look like a t-rex you know why t-rex
have little tiny hands why
it's because they're such adept hunters
they evolved
out of having the use of arms to make
their head bigger
and to make their bodies more agile i've
been listening i've been learning a lot
about dinosaurs because
because theodore's obsessed with them
that's dope yeah t-rex are
really cool animals actually are we
playing the meme game oh my god i forgot
about the meme game do you want to talk
about the dog killers real fast i had
more about that
i've always hated nikki philippi that's
my biggest flex
get to the main game today we're having
fun
people always get mad when we rush so
let's just just have fun
okay well we always have next week we've
got about 15 minutes left we'll probably
have time to do a couple
that's your weather yeah i love that one
okay so well anyway the dog killers you
guys probably all heard i talked about
it on friday
you've talked about i've always uh wait
i haven't talked about it wherever i
talked about it you didn't talk about on
twitter anywhere no
or tick tock even no oh you're slacking
because no they'll take it down on tick
tock tick tock so i'm going to talk
about stuff like that like animal abuse
it's so soft lately that's okay it's a
safe space for people
but i i've always hated nikki philippi
there's old videos of me saying
she she was that girl that had like 50
000 subscribers and had like four
assistants and they would do like group
meetings at like a tea like a coffee
bean and tea leaf
and just my team and i are meeting she
was always that [ __ ] and i would be
careful she's going to send you a note
from her legal team
they're very like super christian which
the they give songs a bad name which i
[ __ ]
hate like i just oh they're so annoying
okay so i learned a lot about her
and i i actually think those two couple
are like beyond [ __ ]
uh wow just horrible they were gonna die
yeah so their dog you got just update
you guys really quickly
their dog that they've had for 10 years
as part of their family
then they got since he was a very young
beautiful puppy i think or a very young
dog
he made they made all this content with
the dog that was like oh they're child
and baby
so he nipped the kid didn't leave any
permanent damage or anything
just a nip didn't even leave a scar and
so he's like i wanted to take the dog in
back and kill him like old yeller
but we took him the next day of the vet
and put him down and everyone's like
first of all
you're insane you're insane for so many
reasons okay obviously that's crazy
that's the reader's digest
but then when i started digging in i
think this is what you were going to
talk about
yeah they're psychotic so they they were
trying to adopt a kid
from here let me let me let me play this
so they're trying to adopt the kid from
thailand and listen to why they dropped
the adoption
and she was like well yes but
also thailand has a its own law that's
unique to it
that um after you are you pick up your
child and they're your
child you are not allowed to talk about
them or
share any images photos videos anything
about them
online for a year maybe to protect the
child from freaks like you
yeah like the couple who did that on
youtube they sent their baby back to
china after two years
yeah exactly that would definitely be
them
what is with people it's so crazy yo
so they didn't adopt the baby because
they couldn't film it for a year
they couldn't make content with this
baby for a year so they're like i have
[ __ ] this kid we didn't like him
anyway
there's some he's like yo i was about to
take that kid in back like old yeller
that's what he said about his dog that's
crazy
it's so insane it's so necessary i hate
that
okay and then there's another one um
hang on i've got a lot i've got a lot of
uh juice on them
uh currently under fire putting their
dog right saw that one
also i mean this is like why i like i
don't know the whole thing
and then here's another one they're
trying to get a kid out of foster care
and they get that first of all these
people are getting denied and then
here's the dog he killed by the way oh
my god here's the beautiful sweet you
can see how
here's you can see how sweet and
submissive that is a loving
yeah like a precious animal yeah did you
see the clips that i'm like taunting him
with the other little baby dog
and like it's like what are you you guys
are the [ __ ] raising him like and he
still seems so sweet he was the one
scared of the little dog like it's so
so here's the dog they killed and then
here's them talking about
um oh my god why they couldn't foster
a child ridiculous to be like
okay there is a rule you can't speak a
foster child
you can't hit your child and there's a
video of them talking about how they
spanked
their kids or something he's like oh i'm
not allowed to hit my foster kids
after they had their baby i don't know
they have like a little baby now the
baby was in the picture
and this is before i don't know what
here and then people go oh yeah we
spanked our kids in the past but we
don't even do it anymore
you could still they said in our foster
class
you can i can't get over what a sweet
dog this is though like [ __ ] you dude
take your hand off that dog you sick
[ __ ] dog murder oh my god
they make me sick they're such weirdos
parent your kids however you want to if
you still spank this how the dog loves
you how could you betray that dog i
would rather die than that's so weird
it's so confusing
look how that dog loves and trusts you
dude
shame on you i'm so sad
you know the reason he put the dog down
because the his kid kept like grabbing
and and
theodore does the same thing he's around
the same age he doesn't understand how
to be gentle with the dog so he grabs
them and
sometimes the dogs growled him but you
have to you have to put in the time to
so that everybody learns how to interact
with each other or just send them to a
house with no kids like dalmatians they
always get like rehomed why didn't they
do that do you have an excuse for it
they said oh we couldn't re-home him
because he was too
he's been with us for too long what
someone would take that
yeah of course but but so apparently
when the dog's eating and the kid grabs
at the food the dog like
uh snips at him so he's like okay put
the dog in the closet and
feed him where the kid can't fight like
a psycho
why did they post a video about it that
was so weird that's the weirdest part
they thought they were going to get all
the sympathy views
look how this look how this dog trusts
him dude i hope you watch this video
oh man i feel like a murderer so sad
oh my god i love my dog so
much i would never ever do anything to
her yeah i wasn't only like nine i mean
he's not bad old i mean
or something yeah yeah not at all dogs
can live up to like you know 14 15 years
that's fine but you can't speak spank a
foster kid
they have to negate you they actually
said you might want to consider changing
that
right but they can't make you yeah but
they okay dude how about don't hit your
kids wait
don't kill your dogs what's the issue
like they apparently he wants to be able
to spank his foster kid
and they're like you can't do that wait
they told the foster system that they're
like we want to spank our kids
here let's let me fly i don't get it let
me play it supposedly
if there's two different types of
discipline going on in the household
it causes more issues but
to hear someone say i don't do it
anymore
and then deny them because they've
spanked their kid in the past
is completely
yeah well you killed your dog that loved
you unconditionally
that's so sad like that though i mean
that dog deserves
the whole people we're not worthy of
dogs are angels on earth and we're not
worthy of them
you know i was never a dog person before
my dog and he literally does just give
like
so much love that's all they do all they
do is i just want to kiss you and like
love you it's like
that's it you know for a christian he
killed an angel so
yeah they're like human they're like a
living being you're not supposed to just
like
dude my dogs are my kids they're my
children well on that note
that kind of leads us to where we're at
right now
[Music]
i it's hard to even understand what kind
of psychotic [ __ ] though oh we're doing
like videos the way they talk about like
trauma it's like such a weird
so that i i honestly ah
these i don't know bro well they've been
canceled like i think you mentioned on
friday's show they can't only like 20
000 no one really cares about them but
now they're really
that video was just so bizarre and then
in the video it's still up
it's still up but they disabled wow why
don't they keep it up
i just can't go over in that original
video he goes i grew up watching old
yeller
so stupid and i wanted to take him in
the back and kill him right
and put him down like that you know what
old yeller is yeah it's a dog that got
rabies defending the family
and it was this heart-drenching moment
because rabies is
is deadly incurable in a dog and it
makes them act
violent so to put down the family dog
that saved their lives
your dog took a little nip at your kid
didn't harm him at all
a very solvable situation and you want
to put him out like old yeller
they're nuts i hate i've always not like
them
so angry about that yeah that's really
that was really sad that was really
free brittany whatever yadda yadda
oh they so they're okay about free
brittany you might find this interesting
okay
the reason there was a big mystery
around how her dad
jamie spears was able to get
into this conservatorship to begin with
the judge for example in the documentary
said
that um there's a reason that he's not
going to disclose
that like apparently so what he got her
in he marked her as
having dementia
at 27. 27.
when she was like still touring and
stuff yeah exactly
dementia damn so anyway she's she's
gonna go
soon coming up in june is going to get
to
speak on behalf of herself at a
consensus
uh conservatorship hearing which has
never happened before
wow do you think she's going to though
yeah she's set to
set to appear in court on june 23rd to
discuss her 13
year long conservatorship i wonder
what's gonna happen
i think there's enough public pressure
40 now so she's been in that for so long
like her whole 30s that's crazy
it's absolutely [ __ ] agreed just that
her dad is obviously a piece of [ __ ]
yikes so that would be interesting
bill gates got a divorce what do you
think eligible bachelor eligible
bachelor
i love these tick tocks the girls like
twerking on him like hey daddy i always
had a dream
yeah i could go over for bill gates for
sure you think so yeah you'd be into
that
yeah what do you think happened do you
think he cheated dan has a really crazy
thing i want to hear it
what's the theory you want to say it dan
well i mean it's not just mine it might
be you might be hearing from his legal
team yeah exactly he actually has a
legal team probably
bill gates you don't want a lawyer from
bogus no i mean it was reported over the
weekend that um
uh at least one of the factors is that
his uh ties to jeffrey epstein
are you familiar with who that is trisha
no but we talked about him on the show
before
you don't know who jeffrey epstein he
died
yes yes he did he did a lot more than
that
okay assuming that he got unalive he was
like uh he was a
prolific uh trafficker of of child
sex slaves right to rich and powerful
people i always forget this but yeah i
think i remember now
so bill gates had an association with
him go ahead dan
yeah and apparently his wife did not
like that
and uh it's something that uh we were
discussing before the show is it's
interesting she
started meeting with divorce lawyers i
guess in october of 2019
and in september of 2019
uh one month prior to that is when ronan
farrow posted a bombshell article
uh in the new yorker i think about
bill gates ties to him and everything um
so new yorker yeah interesting timing on
all of that
is uh so why would she not still go
through with the divorce that'd be more
reason to right
well she did but she did like she was
working on it it's been in the works for
a while get a divorce when you've got
like you know 200 billion dollars
i would say keep it good riddance i
don't want your money
uh she's entitled to half they've been
married 30 years yeah but if he has that
blood money from like children and stuff
like he's got microsoft money blood
money who will use micro you don't want
100 billion i'm a mac [ __ ]
you wouldn't take 100 billion no i want
blood money you are messing with
children take that money i don't think
he was profiting from it he might have
been
if that guy was i'm taking the money
take the money give it to
okay trisha whatever you take the money
i wouldn't take them oh please
if it's like those kind of ties don't
they sacrifice children and stuff
like oh do you know what i'm saying i
don't want to be related
i don't want any ties to that take the
money and then build and then make like
a superhero like
an anti-trafficking league you probably
can do that anyways
if she takes the money she has money
probably what's she doing her
money's all microsoft money too perfect
she actually she worked for microsoft as
well
valerie do you mean money i'm taking the
money i i think i read that they didn't
have a prenup
of course not they've been married 30
years well i mean he was
he was already extremely wealthy i don't
like these prenup conversations like
people are like oh bill gate's such an
idiot he didn't get a prenup it's like
i'm sorry
they've been married 30 years they have
three kids she's
she's been working her ass off to
support this [ __ ] guy
she deserves half i'm sorry that'd be
like if someone's like oh my god you
guys didn't get a prenup you're like oh
we had no money so
yeah it's like of course why would but
like she she's been there for 30 years
supporting his [ __ ] ass
you know yeah if prenups make sense to
in some situations when in their
situation it didn't make sense
you can't spend that much money anyways
in your lifetime he's like whatever take
it [ __ ] yeah he's like i don't even
[ __ ] notice that's what i would say
with her too i'd be like oh whatever
money is whatever i really don't care
i like money but i'll take the hundred
billion i don't need what do you do with
a hundred billion dollars i'll set up a
[ __ ]
i'll set up like a i'll set up the
justice league dude what's that to fight
human trafficking i'll get like
superheroes i'll have like a space
station where they chill
not real oh superheroes suck anyone who
likes superhero movies are weird
no i'm just pissed off like half the
world or more me marvel
marvel who's thanos i don't know i just
thanos you out of existence
wow i'm still here no wait yeah i just
put negative
no you're gonna get it back you're gonna
get that banana
is that what he does because that sounds
like a lame superhero
stop it who's the is he the one with the
gauntlet
yes okay i see people do that because
they put all the people that i don't
like that have gotten like cancelled
see that's a good meme that's all right
should we do a quick meme game
we're pretty much out of time well we
have we have uh
we have the ad record too so well we
don't because we have the ad
doesn't look like that when you go in
why would you fist a cow what do you
think about the stuff
what are you talking about that's how
you take the poop out of a cow why are
you taking poop out of a cup i don't
know i've seen people do it though they
tip their arm all the way up there and
they take it out
why what videos or maybe that's how they
give birth someone casts a stick up
there and they take the baby that makes
sense why would you take poop out of a
cow's butt i don't know
you wanna show me fisting a cow one more
time jesus trisha
you got some weird fantasies
can i also say elon musk was not the
first autistic person to host us now we
just have to clarify that it was
it was dan akroyd oh is he autistic yeah
and so is moses so he's a teacher you
know what's interesting
he said he was the first person with
asperger's but apparently that's an
outdated term
did you know that dan people were upset
that he said he had asperger's because
apparently that's like an outdated term
that isn't specific
enough i i i didn't know about that it
was interesting i mean he's the one with
it apparently they they discontinued
like scientific i might be speaking i
turned i read this
they discontinued that diagnosis because
it's not
specific enough ass burglary
you're acting a little ass burghery
right now yeah me
i just no you're fine moe's
for sure asperger i said that to him
last year because i think my brother has
that too
my brother oh we needed your brother the
other day i was adding numbers together
i'm like i really wish i had ethan's
brother here right now
it's really interesting though the whole
oh what do you got
dan's fast checking the asperger thing
uh yeah that does seem to be the case
but it it
this oh there you go asperger's syndrome
is no longer article diagnosis
april 3rd of this year so this is yeah
it's a brand new thing well then what do
people ups i mean well it's people
really they didn't get the memo
2021 i just thought it was really
interesting so what's the explanation
for asperger's being uh uh no longer a
dike
it sounds like what you were saying it
was the diagnosis
oh it's a high functioning autism so
they felt like it was kind of like
derogatory to other people with autism
it's like
oh well asperger's is we're the
high-functioning ones and you people
with autism are like
functions yeah that's from [ __ ] i'd
be mad too we're all the same we're all
autistic here well
yeah it's because they say that if
there's a what do they say it's a
scale or a or a spectrum spectrum right
where am i on the spectrum i wonder
maybe she'll see a doctor about that i
think i have too many things wrong with
me i don't think i have autism i don't
think you have autism you know
not that there's anything wrong with
autism i don't want to say that i mean
there's something wrong with you
i am just saying you yeah normalize that
normalized threats
dude there's a lot of i mean bill gates
has autism
speaking of which oh he has like what
they used to call asperger's
but there's a like there's a people with
autism that are like really [ __ ]
um interest like unbelievably successful
interesting
people you know what i mean um what is
that what is it is it
it's not what is it what is it
classified as like not a mental illness
but what
it's not an illness it's like a syndrome
it's kind of i guess like tourette's
maybe
i don't know how do you diagnose this is
like the autism part of the show
uh it's a developmental disorder
developmental disorder it's
characterized by like uh
having a hard time with social cues and
uh
i think that's basically it right like
on the high
functioning end
yeah no ticks though well on the low on
the like
low functioning end it can get really
complicated so i'm not sure how
how to differentiate the two but
tourette's is not autism
different no but it's the same brain
imbalance or something no different
issue completely and by the way we
interviewed white claw
gabe just to touch on my god nobody
knows about white call game on this show
we interviewed white club game the guy
goes it's friday baby yeah
[ __ ] yeah who deserves fried chicken
meat
and because you we were arguing about it
last episode that he has tourettes it
wasn't the last episode it was on the
bus off camera
no it was we did it on the show didn't
we dan
interview him yeah we talked to him yeah
no he's saying we talked no
trisha we argued on the show she was
saying that he has autism no
yeah uh no that he has tourettes oh [ __ ]
i mean
yes right i i think that one yeah and so
i asked him
yes and i asked him and he said no i
just like saying [ __ ] for the views baby
so somebody would say with tourette that
you can't that's
just not that's just not cool you got to
stop i like to rise i do i
have to stop pretending like you know
anything about trump i like people with
tourette's i can't say that
you can say that but don't start
diagnosing people diagnosing
you you literally diagnosed him and then
argued with me when i said he didn't
have tourette's
you have to stop i apologize thank you i
liked your
okay sometimes good can i say something
but i don't want to come across offense
because it doesn't mean
i think it's funny go ahead but i don't
want to offend you
it sounds like you're going to i know
i'm not trying to i noticed something
and it was really cute but i don't want
to offend it
go ahead if i do i'll apologize okay
um i thought it was so cute when we were
doing that i was watching the disneyland
vlog and like your tourettes was making
the little porky kind of like dance a
little
oh it was funny yeah yeah i'm not
offended about it is i don't know
it was so funny and i was like oh he
looks like he's like dancing
yeah one of my sometimes i do like this
i thought that was so cute
okay go watch the disney porky on my
shoulder that was i guess dancing no i'm
not
noticing i'm not offended by that yeah
it was actually cute but i don't know if
that's
no that's not offensive at all i think
it's funny a funny observation because
sometimes i talk to myself but that's
like my you know
voices so that's why i was like i don't
know if that's offensive but if
someone's like hey trisha's talking to
herself i don't find that offensive no
all right well we gotta wrap it up and
said uh it's been two hours
was this i feel like this was low energy
because it's like gloomy you know it was
like the weekend
i thought it was fine we kept the i i
don't know it is what it is you know
i'm down to do more vlogs i just don't
know
well let's let's put a bunch of ideas in
a hat dan's doing this
no what moses
oh so yeah leave a comment and we're
smashing like we're subscribing
the interaction oh yeah give oh
guys if you have ideas for us to vlog
next go ahead we're all ears if anyone
has connections at medieval times in
scottsdale like
you wanna oh we should joust yeah i
wanna do that that would be [ __ ]
awesome someone's gonna get hurt
oh yeah for sure jousting
that sounds crazy do you think a horse
could bear your load
bury a load what does that mean
i said do you think a horse can bear
your load bury your load
bear bear your load like [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i don't know what the
meme is
all right okay we'll be back
well i weigh the same amount so like as
the joke equally applies to me i'm
okay okay uh thanks for watching guys
can i end it
oh yeah yeah yeah go ahead here all
right
all right thank you guys for watching
this episode of frenemies we will be
back
next tuesday with another new episode
baby and costume let us know who we
should cosplay next don't forget to
smash that like button hit subscribe
turn on the bell notifications
so you do not miss us and we are not
shadow band shout out to philip defranco
who is now friend of the show
and uh check him out too phillyd okay
bye
no the microphone's gone that's it bye
[Music]
you